on va dire que ça fonctionne c'est bon
on va dire que ça fonctionne
alors amis du jour bonjour j'espère que
ça marche et que vous m'entendez écoutez
merci pour le merci à joël et
jean-pierre d'avoir organisé ce facebook
live au débotté pour une édition
spéciale pâtisserie dans parents spécial
quant aux navires us depuis londres non
pas depuis londres depuis chez moi alors
je vais prendre les questions pas
exactement dans l'ordre de celles qui
ont reçu le plus de soutien mais dans un
ordre un peu plus chronologique et un
peu plus séquentiel d'abord il ya une
question que je n'ai pas vu je sais pas
si elle existe quelque part mais
peut-être que oui mais sinon c'est pas
grave je vais y répondre quand même qui
est est ce qu'il ya un lien quelconque
entre ce qui est en train de nous
arriver et la question du réchauffement
climatique en fait la réponse est enfin
oublier qu te ment entre ce qui est en
train de nous arriver les couples
énergie climat alors la réponse est oui
pas de façon directe c'est-à-dire que
évidemment on peut pas dire que le
coronavirus serait pas arrivé s'il n'y
avait pas eu ou le réchauffement
climatique ou le pétrole
par contre ce qui est certain c'est que
nous sommes en train en ce moment de
vivre grandeur nature une
déstabilisation à court terme d'un
système qui est fait pour être très
performante en tout va bien et qui
a beaucoup de mal à fonctionner très de
sa zone ordinaire on va dire que là on
fonctionne tout de suite dans un mode
qui est raisonnablement dégradée par
rapport aux par rapport à son mode
ordinaire quand il commence à y avoir un
petit grain de sable alors je m'explique
l'énergie abondante a fait comme un
certain nombre de gens qui écoutent le
savent
un monde mondialisé c'est grâce au
pétrole qu'on a modélisé des échanges un
monde urbain
c'est grâce à l'énergie abondante qu'on
a réussi à mettre les gens entassés dans
les villes un monde de grandes
organisations avant l'énergie abondante
il n'existait pas une société suis
peut-être l'église dans laquelle on
trouvait des centaines de milliers de
gens et des sites uniques avec des
dizaines de milliers de salariés et le
l'énergie a donc fait ce donc pas donc
façonner un monde dans lequel par
construction c'est plus facile à une
petite bestiole de se propager et quand
on empêche la bestiole de se propager
où ça désorganise instantanément la
totalité de ce qu'on a besoin de faire
parce que ça désorganise instantanément
le fonctionnement des grandes
organisations des villes et des flux des
changes
donc il ya un lien évident entre entre
ce que nous sommes en train de vivre et
le qu'est ce que je veux dire et le fait
que notre civilisation et ce soit
structurée d'une certaine manière avec
l'énergie qui est qui a été disponible
pendant deux siècles
alors ça veut pas du tout dire qu'on ait
construit un monde qui soit plus fragile
que ce qu'il était il ya deux siècles
parce que il ya deux siècles on n'était
pas capable de résister à une pandémie
qui par ailleurs se répandait quand même
alors la peste date pas d'il ya deux
siècles mais
là il ya eu des époques dans le passé on
était quand même beaucoup plus
vulnérable face à ce qui est en train de
face aux faces aux petites bêtes en ce
qui concerne le changement climatique
c'est évident que le lien restera à
jamais impossible à établir
parce que c'est dans l'autre sens qu'il
est facile à faire quand on chauffe le
bouillon de culture c'est ça favorise la
multiplication des roues plus exactement
ça profite un certain nombre de micro
organismes et donc c'est quelque chose
qui va je conclus at il favorisé très
vraisemblablement l'apparition plus
rapide d'un certain nombre de choses
d'agents pathogènes dont on se serait
bien passé voilà bien évidemment il ya
strictement aucun lien formel qui peut
être fait entre ce qui est en train de
nous arriver et la question du et la
question du climat
voilà donc une fois qu'on a qu'on a
répondu à ça la question c'est à partir
de là qu'est ce qu'on fait alors la
première question à laquelle je vais
répondre qui est aussi celle qui a
recueilli le plus grand nombre de
suffrages
c'est est ce qu'on peut tirer parti de
la situation actuelle pour organiser un
nouveau fonctionnement le la réponse est
oui et non alors je vais être un tout
petit peu plus précis le gouvernement
aujourd'hui il est pris totalement au
dépourvu par une situation qui est hors
norme
c'est à dire que aujourd'hui il n'y a
pas dans les cartons à l'échelle du pays
quelque chose qui correspond à un mode
de fonctionnement planifié dans la
situation qui est aujourd'hui la nôtre
il ya des organisations qui sont
capables de prévoir des modes de
fonctionnement dégradé par exemple pour
répondre à une autre question à laquelle
je répondrai plus tard et des f&a un
plan pandémie
c'est à dire que ça fait longtemps que
ils se sont posé la question de savoir s
il nous manque 10 % des gens et 20 % des
gens et 30% des gens et 40% des gens
comment est ce qu'on fait en ce qui
concerne l'état alors il ya d'autres
systèmes qui ont des plans comme ça qui
sont faits pour être capable de vaincre
pour penser le fonctionnement en mode
dégradé par contre au niveau de l'état
dans son ensemble le fonctionnement en
mode dégradé il et il n'existe pas et en
particulier pas avec les gens qui sont
obligés de rester chez eux sauf pour
motif essentiel
une fois que j'ai dit ça il ya plein de
gens qui commencent à s'exprimer sur le
mode on vous l'avait bien dit sauf que
on vous l'avait bien dit c'est pas un
plan donc malheureusement ça sera pas
audible dans le contexte actuel parce
que ce qui est audible dans le contexte
actuel malheureusement c'est les plans
qui avait été pensé avant que la
surprise n'arrive
dit autrement quand on est pris au
dépourvu c'est pas à ce moment là que on
change on sort pas qu'il ya des saints
et qu'on commence à dessiner un mouton à
ce moment là tout ce qu'on est capable
de faire c'est d'activer des plans qui
avait déjà été préparée avant or il se
trouve que malheureusement le seul plan
qui a déjà été préparé avant pour
essayer de remettre le système sur les
rails
c'est très exactement 2 on recommence
alors je vais être un peu plus précis
aujourd'hui il ya par exemple les
compagnies aériennes qui sont au tapis
directement leurs avions sont au sol
dans l'espace de vraiment pas longtemps
elles vont à peu près tout faire
faillite
on pourrait très bien se dire bon que
d'un mâle sorte un bien puisque les
avions arrête de volée que les gens qui
survivent et bien on ne relance pas le
système tel qu'il est et l'argent qu'on
va injecter à partir de maintenant il
est pas fait pour faire voler des avions
il est fait pour convertir les gens qui
travaillaient dans le monde aérien pour
qu'ils se mettent à faire autre chose
on pourrait le faire sauf que comme il
ya strictement aucun plan qui a été
proposée avant que la crise n'arrive
pour faire ce genre de choses dit
autrement il n'y a rien sur la table
et bien ce qui va être fait très
vraisemblablement à la volée c'est que
le gouvernement va ou nationalisés air
france ou faire quelque chose
d'équivalent pour essayer de faire
repartir le système comme il était une
fois que l'urgence est passé c'est
exactement pareil
pour le pétrole aux états unis à cause
de la baisse du prix du pétrole
alors qu'il ya un lien avec le
coronavirus évidemment j'y viendrai
quand on parlera du pétrole
avec la baisse du prix du pétrole est
bien une bonne partie des exploitants de
pétrole dits de schiste aux états unis
sont en très grande difficulté et le
gouvernement a l'intention de les aider
à surmonter cette difficulté pas du tout
de profiter du fait qu'ils vont pas être
capable de sortir du pétrole de terre en
se disant bon on va essayer de
s'organiser un peu différemment et des
voitures plus petites et des gens qui
prennent un peu moins l'avion donc le
donc la réponse est que en période de
crise
mon expérience c'est que on ne fait rien
d'autre que sortir des cartons les plans
qui avait été conçu avant alors après ça
va dépendre de la longueur de la crise
c'est à dire que si dans un premier
temps ont fait repartir les activités et
puis qu'on a un deuxième accident
derrière je ne sais pas et que parce que
c'est parfaitement possible et en fait
j'en vois un veut dire qu'il va être une
récession en plus de celle du
coronavirus et j'y viendrai aussi quand
on reparlera du pétrole mais si derrière
il ya un deuxième accident à ce moment
il est possible que les gens qui ont
encore un peu le temps de réfléchir en
ce moment et qui se mettent à eux sortir
la planche à dessin pour voir comment on
pourrait s'y prendre
il est possible qu'ils deviennent
audibles dans six mois ou dans un an
quand il y aura j'ai envie de dire la
deuxième passe et que à ce moment là les
les chakras sont un peu plus ouvert
voilà mon sentiment c'est que ça va se
faire en trois temps cette histoire donc
dans un premier temps on gère l'urgence
donc en ce moment c'est même pas la
peine de parler de quoi que ce soit
concernant le plan de relance à qui que
ce soit parce que de toute façon tout
l'exécutif géré l'urgence une fois que
l'urgence sera derrière nous c'est à
dire qu'on aura commencé à contenir
l'épidémie
à ce moment là
les plans de relance qui seront activés
et seront des plans de relance à mon
avis très exactement à l'identique
sauf à ce que les gens qui sont l'objet
des plans de relance aient eux mêmes des
demandes pour se relancer de façon un
peu plus verte et qu'ils y aient pensé à
l'avance et dans un troisième temps
seulement ce qui est en train d'être
éventuellement penser aujourd'hui sera
discutable au moment où la relance
elle-même s'essoufflera parce que il est
vraisemblable que on est un problème
avec la relance elle même annoncé là que
je vais venir à notre question donc je
vais faire un petit petit aller-retour
sur la question pétrole et co2 parce que
j'ai vu que la question avait été posée
également
alors qu'est ce qui se passe en ce
moment sur le pétrole une des
explications que j'ai entendu c'est que
nous sommes déjà en fait dans l'après
pic et que on est déjà en train de vivre
une situation de déflation et que cette
situation a été engendrée par le choc
pétrolier qui s'est étalée de 2008 à
2014 et qui lui même a été provoqué par
le pic de production du pétrole
conventionnel
alors je leur fais dans l'ordre 2008
nous dit l'agencé internationale de
l'énergie le pétrole conventionnel passe
par un pic
du coup on a ce qu'il est coutume
d'appeler maintenant la crise des
subprimes est en fait qui en fait est
une crise énergétique à la base d'abord
le pétrole commence à se faire un peu
plus rares ou plus exactement il
n'augmente plus le pib des salaires et
le système financier américain se
détricote là dedans le prix du pétrole
remontent très fortement du coup les
investissements dans l'amont pétrolier
triple en l'espace de quelques années on
racle un peu mieux les fonds de tiroirs
et surtout on se met à lancer la
production de shell oil
mais laquelle est beaucoup plus
difficile techniquement et beaucoup
moins rentable économiquement que la
production de pétrole conventionnel qui
elle est en train de décliner et
le système en novembre 2018 arrive un
pic depuis lequel la production décline
et se pique engendre lui-même un début
de difficultés économiques on voyait
bien la croissance était en train de
baisser partout la production
industrielle de l'allemagne commencé à
souffrir et c est ce pic engendre un
début de diminution du prix du pétrole
et à ce moment le système s'emballe le
mais les foreurs de chez lloyd en
difficulté supprimer encore plus les
investissements et là dessus arrive le
corps en a bien eu ce qui est le coup de
grâce en faisant tomber le prix du baril
à un niveau qui est tellement bas que
les investissements vont vont continuer
à baisser alors là dessus qu'est ce
qu'il va se passer il va se passer que
comme les investissements dans le shale
oil qui était le seul réservoir de
croissance avec les sables bitumineux
baisse du coup la production de chez
lloyds va s'arrêter de croître voir se
mettre à baisser dans les pronostics
qu'on commence à voir passer ici et là
il y avait un article je suis dans le ft
je crois aujourd'hui dix ans que 2020
pourrait très pourrait très bien 30 ou
40 dollars le baril être l'année du pic
de production du shale oil a ce moment
la production mondiale de pétrole se met
à baisser et comme l'activité économique
suit au premier ordre
ou plus exactement ne peut pas être plus
importante c'est plutôt ça qu'il faut
voir que la production de pétrole série
peut y avoir autre chose qu'il entame
par exemple korda violence mais en tout
cas ça borne supérieure son enveloppe
c'est la quantité de pétrole disponible
et comme cette quantité baisse ça veut
dire que la reprise les plans de reprise
ne donneront pas les effets escomptés
c'est là que je voulais en venir
dit autrement à un moment on retombe sur
un défaut de pétrole pour que les plans
de relance s'applique à plein et donc ce
qui va se passer c'est qu'on va injecter
plein d'argent c'est un peu comme le
quantitative easing après 2008
on va injecter plein d'argent et la
relance économique ne suivra pas donc
c'est à ce moment là et à ce moment là
seulement que peut-être il commencera à
y avoir une opportunité pour que les
oreilles s'ouvrent et qu'on essaye de
faire différemment alors ce différemment
il demande des dirigeants des mesures
qui là aussi pour le moment sont très
très peu disponible sur la table parce
que en gros ça revient à faire face à
des problèmes qui augmente avec des
moyens qui baisse
or personne aujourd'hui y compris chez
les écologistes c'est ça qui est très
drôle
personne aujourd'hui n'a ce type de
cahier des charges en tête
si on prend nos amis de négawatt par
exemple la contrepartie économique de
l'an scénario c'est la croissance c'est
à dire que quand ils ont fait le volet
économique de la scénario ça se fait
dans un monde en croissance
la slbc française qui prévoit une très
forte baisse de la consommation
d'énergie fossile info exactement qui
scénarise pour prévoir une très forte
baisse de la consommation d'énergie
fossile et bien elle se fait dans le
cadre d'un monde en croissance
le scénario 2 degrés de la lieu qui est
aussi un scénario qui est censé
permettre d'avoir une économie qui se dé
carbone se fait dans un monde en
décroissance en croissance par le lapsus
et le green deal européen se pensent
également dans un monde en en croissance
donc aujourd'hui sur la table à dessin
il n'y a pas de plan pour gérer un monde
avec moins de moyens
dit autrement les gens qui ont pensé des
mesures activable dans un monde dans
lequel globalement les moyens baissent
et je parle des moyens physiques dont
les moyens économiques ne sont qu'une
représentation mais dans un monde dans
lequel des moyens physiques baisse pour
le moment les gens qui ont tenté d'y
réfléchir sont comment dire rares roshi
project c'est ça qu'on essaye de faire
soit dit en passant on a déjà essayé de
réfléchir en ce sens et on va à la
faveur de ce qui est en train de nous
arriver
essayez d'accoucher d'une espèce de
crash programme ou deux
deux plans qu'on pourrait proposer dont
on ne pense pas qu'il sera encore une
fois audible dans les mois qui viennent
mais par contre on espère vraiment que
dans les dents dans l'année n'importe
quand on entre maintenant et la
prochaine élection présidentielle si la
situation dégénère pas trop on aura une
fenêtre de tir pour le présenter parce
que encore une fois je pense que
malheureusement la réalité c'est que
quand tu auras des plans de relance ses
plans de relance vont buter sur la
baisse de la production de pétrole alors
accessoirement au moment où il y aura
des plans de relance et une production
de pétrole en baisse
la logique voudrait qu'il y ait dans un
nouveau choc pétrolier c'est à dire qu'à
ce moment là le prix du pétrole remonte
très rapidement comme vous avez pu le
constater ces derniers temps le prix du
pétrole est devenue maintenant
extrêmement volatile donc il est capable
de fluctuer à la hausse comme à la
baisse très rapidement et donc je ne
serai pas plus étonné que sa ci-après
être à 20 dollars le baril un an après
deux ans après il se baladait à 100
dollars le baril je pense que tout ça
fait partie des choses possibles
donc j'ai pas du tout en train de faire
une prévision je suis juste en train de
dire que c'est très très difficile
aujourd'hui de faire des pronostics est
plus que jamais cette blague de
pétroliers me semble valable qui est
vous pouvez donner un prix et vous
pouvez donner une date
mais surtout j'avais les deux en même
temps voilà donc le pétrole va être un
facteur limitant de la reprise alors
après est ce que ça veut dire que le
pétrole de schiste américain va voir sa
bulle éclatée ça dépend ce qu'on appelle
une bulle ce qui me paraît clair c'est
que le pétrole est tellement stratégique
pour les etats-unis que je pense que les
états unis vont soutenir leurs
pétroliers par tous les moyens possibles
y compris en demandant aux actionnaires
et aux prêteurs de s'asseoir sur la
montagne de dettes ce que les pétroliers
ont contracté espère que le scénario le
plus probable pour moi c'est pas que les
foreurs de pétrole de schiste font
faillite et que du coup il ya plus de
pétrole qui y sort je pense que s'il ya
un problème d'approvisionnement les
foreurs sont faillite et ils repartent
comme com
comment 40 derrière tout simplement
parce que vous savez qu aux etats unis
comme en france il ya une loi sur les
retraites manger this year chapter
eleven aux états unis qui permet de
redémarrer l'activité à l'abri de ses
créanciers
donc je pense que c'est la production
elle-même elle sera limitée aux
etats-unis beaucoup plus par des
facteurs géologiques et techniques que
par des facteurs financiers le cheylas
il n'a pas gagné d'argent en cash flow
depuis ses origines ça ne m'empêche pas
d'avoir continué à produire de plus en
plus je suis pas complètement convaincu
qu' il va s'arrêter de produire tout
simplement parce qu'il a des difficultés
économiques aujourd'hui qui peut pas
rembourser ses créanciers je pense que
du point de vue des etats-unis s'est pas
complètement un sujet donc est ce que la
bulle va éclater au sens où il va y
avoir de la dette pourrie qui sera pas
remboursé s'apprête vraisemblablement
parce que ça va empêcher les producteurs
de pêches et l'oeil de produits c'est
pas sûr
est-ce que ça va avoir un effet
systémique sur l'économie je ne crois
pas parce que ça représente un paquet
dette mais ça représente beaucoup plus
petits paquets de dette que la tête des
états donc je pense que ça et c'est
beaucoup plus petit que le crédit
immobilier qui a mis le feu aux poudres
en 2008 donc je prend complètement sûr
que ce soit un risque systémique
par contre je le redis ce que je crois
c'est que la baisse des investissements
d'une manière générale dans le monde en
a pas qu'aux états unis avec un pétrole
à 20 ou 30 $ va avoir un effet sur la
production
on peut rajouter à ça le fait que l'un
des producteurs majeurs aujourd'hui qui
est la russie avait annoncé avant
l'épisode coronavirus et avant l'épisode
pétrole à ma dollars que il escomptait
passé leur pic en 2021 alors personne ne
saura jamais si c'est du bluff
enfin le sort après coup comme
d'habitude mais s'il ya un début de
réalité a ça ça veut dire que il faut
effectivement s'attendre dans les années
qui viennent à des soubresauts 13 est
très important et je le redis au fait
que le plan de relance en 'business as
usual'
pas se heurter de toute façon au mur du
pétrole et que c'est à ce moment là
qu'il faudra être prêt avec des
propositions concrètes pour ne pas que
la population soit laissée dans un
désarroi qui alors là sera extrêmement
extrêmement arriver un autre effet que
ça va avoir le le ya quelqu'un qui me
dit c'est pas le corps d'un virus qui
fait tomber le prix du baril c'est une
conjonction qui fait tomber prix du
baril c'est à dire c'est à la fois le
corps en un virus le fait qu' on était
déjà en économie qui commençait à ceux
des primés et le fait effectivement que
les russes et les saoudiens ont décidé
de ne pas baisser les vannes pour 2 n'a
pas fermé les vannes pour autant c'est
une conjonction de l'ensemble ce qui
[Musique]
donc je le donc je le disais ce qui va
être intéressant c'est de concevoir des
plans de relance qui peuvent passer la
rampe alors une des choses qui
pourraient très bien se produire soit
dit en passant
dans ce contexte là c'est que le soutien
aux énergies renouvelables électriques
qui aujourd'hui consomment de grandes
quantités de capitaux et qui s'occupent
d'un problème notamment en france qui
n'était pas urgent fasse l'objet d'une
réorientation rapide voilà ça c'est
quelque chose qui on voyait déjà les
allemands qui étaient en train de caler
l'année dernière ils ont installé
beaucoup moins d'éolien dans l'année que
ce qu'il faisait les années précédentes
alors par contre ils ont installé pas
mal de soleil il n'est pas du tout il
n'est pas du tout exclu que l'un des
effets collatéraux j'ai envie de dire de
cette affaire-là
c'est que la perfusion d'argent public
qui est nécessaire pour le déploiement
de ces trucs là soit
se tarissent et c'est d'autant plus
possible qu'il peut y avoir un effet
étonnant duo marché aujourd'hui les
tarifs garantis finance un delta entre
le prix de marché la différence entre le
prix de marché et le coût de production
si on a une économie déprimée les prix
de marché devraient logiquement baissé
et donc le la quantité d'argent
nécessaires au soutien financier devrait
à ce moment-là augmenté donc si les prix
de marché et deviennent durablement pas
parce que l'économie on a pris un grand
coup dans le nez et bien c'est quelqu'un
dont on peut très bien avoir un
enchaînement un moins de pétrole du coup
l'économie souffre ou coronavirus du
coup l'économie souffre et du coup
derrière la demande électrique baisse
est à ce moment les prix de
l'électricité deviennent durablement bas
et donc paradoxalement comme pour le
moment les nerfs sont toujours
prioritaires sur le réseau la quantité
d'argent public qu'il faut pour soutenir
cette filière augmente
voilà ça sera intéressant de regarder ce
qui va se passer dans ce domaine là dans
les mois et les années qui viennent
alors dans les questions corollaire
toujours sur le pétrole
il y avait une question qui était
pourquoi ce que les dirigeants européens
ne sont pas plus inquiet que cela face
aux futures difficultés
d'approvisionnement en pétrole
ça rejoint une autre question qu'on a
déposé une fois qui est pourquoi est-ce
qu'on peut manquer de pétrole et ne pas
voir dans le prix la réponse
en fait c'est la même réponse aux deux
questions
c'est tout simplement que comme il n'ya
pas d'élasticité long terme entre le
pétrole et son prix entre la quantité de
pétrole disponible et son prix et que
les dirigeants ne surveille que le prix
en fait il pense que tant que le prix
est bas c'est qu'on n'a pas de problème
d'approvisionnement
ils ne comprennent pas qu'un prix bas
peut signifier qu'on a eu un problème
d'approvisionnement avant et que ça a
cassé l'économie y comprennent pas ça de
même que quand on se dit si le pétrole
coûte pas cher à la pompe c'est qu'un
assez pour tout le monde
en fait quand on se dit ça on n'en
comprend pas que un défaut de pétrole a
déjà pu casser l'économie et à ce moment
il ya juste moins de gens qui ont les
moyens de rouler en voiture et donc
c'est normal que
la pompe le pétrole vaille pas plus cher
parce que la demande l'offre a changé
mais la demande a changé aussi
donc les gens en europe ils sont
intimement persuadés que les marchés
étant parfait si on doit en manquer de
pétrole le prix augmente indéfiniment et
tant que le prix n'augmente pas
indéfiniment ses commandes pas de
pétrole
voilà c'est ça le c'est la raison pour
laquelle ils sont pas ils sont pas
inquiets alors on va revenir à la
question des plans pour l'avenir
il ya une deuxième question qui était
est ce qu'il est possible de vivre
durablement une économique guerre comme
actuellement alors la réponse est un
certain temps puisque malheureusement
dans le passé il ya des guerres qui ont
duré un certain temps
par contre ce qui me paraît clair c'est
que en ce moment on n'est pas juste en
économie guerre on est aussi entre
guillemets en guerre au sens où on s'est
pas contenté de réorienter l'activité
très fortement
plus exactement d'interdire très
fortement certaines activités
j'ai fait un petit calcul si on ajoute
boutabout le tourisme l'enseignement
l'hôtellerie restauration le cas l'autre
comme secteur qui a été très rapidement
contraint évidemment une bonne partie du
tertiaire etc
en fait c'est 30 % d'activité
aujourd'hui en gros c'est 30 % du pib à
qui on vient de demander soit d'arrêter
d'exercer soin de s'organiser de façon
extrêmement différentes
c'est donc effectivement une
réorientation de type économique guerre
mais le supplément qui me fait dire que
effectivement c'est comme si on était en
guerre c'est la liberté de se déplacer
qui vient d'être très très fortement
restreinte c'est à dire que dans une
économie de guerre les gens continuent
d'aller au travail normalement il
continue d'aller manger normalement etc
simplement il ya un certain nombre de
secteurs on leur dit à partir de
maintenant c'est plus simple vous faites
c'est autre chose
l'exemple typique aux etats unis c'est
on a arrêté overnight de faire des
voitures s'est mis à faire des bateaux
et des avions
voilà ça c'est l'économie d'hyères mais
pour autant on n'a pas fermé les
restaurants
on n'a pas empêcher les gens d'aller au
travail on n'a pas supprimé les
rassemblements de plus de 100 personnes
là on a pris les mesures qui sont très
très restrictif sur la liberté et c'est
pas juste une économie de guerre c'est
la guerre
donc on au sens de la privation de
liberté alors la bonne question c'est
combien de temps ça peut durer et je
n'ai pas la réponse à cette question
mon sentiment c'est que ça ne peut pas
durer extrêmement longtemps
il commence à y avoir des analyses
quantitatives qui circulent ici et là
qui ont l'air correctement documenté et
qui disent que pour que le confinement
soit totalement efficace il faudrait
qu'il dure selon les pays
parce que les au moment où on déclare
cette mesure l'épidémie est plus ou
moins avancés selon les pays entre six
mois et 22 mois
j'ai un peu de mal à voir mais encore
une fois les gens sont capables de
choses étonnantes mais j'ai un peu de
mal à voir comment le pays pourrait être
totalement figée dans l'état actuel
pendant un an
alors j'ai un peu de mal pour deux
raisons la première c'est que le il va
finir par y avoir des émeutes c'est à
dire qu'il va finir par y avoir des
endroits où les gens ne fit supporteront
plus physiquement d'être confiné dans un
appartement de 30 mètres carrés toute la
journée avec les enfants qui braillent
le etc
je pense que ça va à un moment de venir
physiquement intolérable et donc il va
se passer des choses
il va y avoir des réactions la deuxième
raison pour laquelle je ne pense pas que
ça puisse durer indéfiniment et la
suivante
mon analyse donc très très rapide c'est
que les mesures que nous venons de
prendre maintenue sur un mois c'est sur
un mois de l'ordre de 20% du pib qui
s'en va je le redis
hôtellerie-restauration ses 8 % du pib
donc plus de restaurants plus d'hôtels
ça veut dire 8% du pib qui disparaît les
transports ces 3 ou 4% du pib donc
disparaît l'enseignement il est fait à
distance mais enfin bon il est fait dans
des circonstances qui sont très
acrobatique parce que tous ceux d'entre
vous dont leurs enfants à la maison
et qui par ailleurs doivent télétravail
et comprendront que de faire les deux en
même temps c'est compliqué alors pendant
15 jours vous pouvez vous mettre en
arrêt maladie aux frais de l'état
mais enfin pendant quinze jours je viens
pendant un an j'ai un peu plus de ne pas
penser que ça va être le cas
je continue dans mon dans mon inventaire
vous avez également toutes les activités
qui sont liées à la culture qu'il y est
d'être arrêtée là aussi il y en a pour 7
ou 8% du pib
donc le cinéma les parcs d'attractions
etc
si on mettait tous à l'arrêt pendant un
an on supprimerait donc allez on va dire
grosse maille 20% du pib français
j'ai un peu de mal à croire que on saura
gérer facilement une récession de
l'ordre de 20% ou en tout cas c'est
évident qu'à ce moment là ça devient un
régime totalitaire parce que les les
débordements que cela occasionnera de
vont nécessiter de basculer dans un
régime qui n'a plus rien à voir avec ce
qu'on connaît aujourd'hui
voilà donc la la la question qui est est
ce qu'on peut vivre durablement en
économie de guerre comme actuellement
la réponse est je ne sais pas parce que
en fait là le vrai enjeu aujourd'hui
c'est pas tellement que l'économie et de
guerre c'est que l'économie ait
contracté séquelles on perd 20% de
l'économie dans cette histoire alors si
on perd 20% de l'économie pendant un
mois
donc on fait une petite règle de trois
ça veut dire qu'on perd 2% de l'économie
pendant un an puis un kit effet rebond
donc effectivement ça fait passer la
croissance qui était envisagée à + 1 %
enfin voir les envisager pourquoi
pourquoi ça plutôt qu'autre chose de ces
braves à -1%
voilà mais après si vous maintenez saad
un deuxième mois et il est pas du tout
exclu que ça doivent être maintenus un
deuxième mois parce qu'aujourd'hui en
termes de confinement on navigue un peu
à vue
à ce moment vous êtes à moins 3 etc si
vous rajoutez 2 % par mois
et vous voyez à l'arrivée ce que ça
donne je le redis je suis j'ai des
doutes
alors après ça avec des doutes un
peut-être l'expérience montrera que je
me trompe mais en tout cas je n'ai pas
de doute sur le fait que si ça doit se
passer ça sera pas du tout le monde
qu'on connaît aujourd'hui la
généralisation du télétravail elle est
possible pour les gens qui sont comme
moi des cadres urbains
elle est encore raisonnablement possible
pour des gens qui ne sait pas travailler
ensemble d'appel et pour qui on peut
faire en sorte que le centre d'appels
soit déporté chez eux
mais enfin pour les gens qui préparent
des repas au restaurant télétravail
c'est compliqué pour des gens qui livre
le télétravail c'est compliqué pour des
gens qui accueillait des visiteurs à
disneyland
non pas que je considère que de perdre
disneyland sur une perte majeure mais ça
faisait quand même beaucoup d'emplois
c'est compliqué et même l'enseignement à
distance
c'est quelque chose qui n'est pas si
simple que ça de façon aussi massive que
ce qui a été décidé donc je ne suis pas
complètement sûr qu'on va y arriver de
façon durable juste avec du télétravail
et puis pas bloquer encore une fois un
pays pendant si longtemps
donc le donc la bonne question est de
savoir combien de temps est-ce que tout
ça va durer c'est à dire combien de
temps est-ce qu'on va arbitrer en faveur
de la sauvegarde d'une partie de la
population et qui au risque de me faire
quelques ennemis
je le répète est quand même une
population qui est pour l'essentiel à g
donc c'est quand même une mesure qui est
en faveur de ceux qui ont déjà bien vécu
puisque le riz est derrière eux et elle
est pour partie en défaveur de ceux
acquis pour qui la vie reste à écrire
puisque le fait de fichiers le pays
comme ça le fish notamment pour
construire un avenir qui serait plus
souriant pour les gens qui sont jeunes
aujourd'hui donc je ne sais pas combien
de temps est-ce que cet arbitrage sera
fait
c
je sais pas j'ai pas david qui est sûr
encore une fois c'est que pour revenir à
la question qui est ce qu'il ya des
opportunités pour parler au gouvernement
dans ce dans ce domaine là ma réponse
est je ne suis pas complètement
persuadés non plus que le gouvernement
ait une idée extrêmement claire
l'instant lance pas là de combien de
temps ça va durer pense que eux aussi
navigue à vue
alors là pour le coup on peut
difficilement leur en faire grief pas ce
que c'est
c'est quelque chose que peu de gens
avaient imaginé conjoncturellement alors
on pourra dire aussi que fallait écouter
les virologues que ça fait longtemps
qu'ils disent qu'il ya une cochonnerie
qui finira par circuler et qu'on n'est
pas du tout organiser pour faire face à
ce genre de trucs et ces gens là ont
malheureusement raison et puis après
pour revenir à mon sujet favori
on peut ne pas être au bout dans un
règlement on peut très bien en plus à
voir cet été une nouvelle canicule
alors que l'on continue à être confiné
avec un problème de ceux ci avec un
problème de cela voilà on peut imaginer
que les emmerdements s'empilent les uns
sur les autres on peut tout à fait faire
ce genre de choses ce qui devrait être
une des réponses à la fois des
gouvernements et des organisations
quelles qu'elles soient
les entreprises l'administration etc
face à ce genre de situation c'est que
ça devrait nous inciter encore plus
qu'avant à faire ce qu'on appelle des
analyses par scénario c'est à dire à ne
pas voir le monde comme une histoire qui
va s'écrire d'une seule manière possible
mais à voir le monde ou à voir l'avenir
plus exactement comme une histoire qui
peut s'écrire de plusieurs façons
différentes
et à ce moment se demander ce qu'on fait
dans chacun des cas de figure c'est
quelque chose que professionnellement il
m'arrive de faire et qui permet de voir
sur un rayon beaucoup plus large que
simplement
on va aller là et puis il ya qu'à
utiliser nos moyens pour y arriver parce
qu'on est sûr d'y arriver
ça permet de voir venir des coûts et de
ceux de ceux du coup de sang prévenir un
peu mieux et dans le monde
facile dans lequel nous avons vécu
pendant de façon croissante pendant deux
siècles on a eu de plus en plus tendance
à abandonner ce raisonnement qui est un
raisonnement prudentielles qu'est ce que
le fait si donc effectivement ses
ascendances assure contrôler incendie
parce que tu vois ça on voit que ça peut
varier
on s'assure complet d'accidents de la
route parce que ça on voit que ça donc
ça peut arriver mais on ne sait pas
encore s'assurer contre les choses qu'on
n'a pas encore vu et c'est pourtant ça
qu'on va devoir
on va devoir apprendre à faire de
manière croissante
c'est vrai contre des choses qu'on n'a
pas encore vu mais qu' un travail
d'analysé par scénario permet quand même
d'imaginer ou en tout cas d'avancée
d'avancé dessus est ce que cette crise
va remettre en cause la délocalisation
de tout ou partie de notre production de
biens ça c'est vraisemblable il paraît
clair que la longueur des chaînes
d'approvisionnement aujourd'hui est un
élément de vulnérabilité la dépendance à
une zone manufacturière un peu trop
concentrés est aussi un élément de
vulnérabilité et le ski et farce si on
peut dire dans cette affaire c'est que
l'industrie pharmaceutique elle-même a
failli se retrouver pris au piège d'un
approvisionnement en provenance d'une
zone qui était fermée pour cause de
quarantaine sanitaire et on en n'est pas
passé loin
en l'occurrence si ça avait été une
autre province chinoise il y avait
quelques grands industriels de la
pharmacie français qui n'aurait pas été
très bien donc le même et c'est une
extension de ce que je disais juste
avant c'est à dire qu'on va devoir
passer comme je l'avais écrit dans une
chronique des échos il ya quelques
années de la performance à la résilience
c'est à dire que si on veut que ce genre
d'épisode ne se reproduise pas ou pas
trop souvent il va falloir accepter un
système qui est moins performant donc il
est dans sa zone de confort mais plus
résilient quand on sort de sa zone de
confort
et aujourd'hui on a construit un système
qui est très performant quand il est
dans sa zone de confort mais extrêmement
peu résilient dès qu'on le sort de sa
zone de confort et sa zone de confort
est assez étroite c'est celle de la
croissance permise par une énergie
croissante à temps quand on sort de
cette zone là est bien le système
comment ça commence à dérailler allez un
p'tit coup de co2 quel est l'impact du
cornât virus sur la consommation
d'énergie fossile et par conséquent de
co2 en europe il ya un papier d'un d'une
entreprise qui dans la spécialité de
faire des analyses sur la consommation
de pétrole
qui a dit que de son point de vue le
coronavirus devrait supprimer au maximum
de son intensité 10% de la consommation
pétrolière dans le monde
donc si on fait une moyenne sur
l'ensemble de l'année parce que eux ils
pensent qu'au deuxième semestre
on sera entre guillemets revenue à la
normale à ce moment ça fait 5 % du
pétrole et le pétrole faisant 30% du co2
ben vous voyez ça fait 1 25% du co2 en
moins sur l'année pour l'ensemble du
monde alors je n'ai pas la réponse pour
l'europe en particulier mais vous voyez
que on est en train de parler d'un
épisode qui bien que il soit très marqué
au moment où ils arrivent et bien sûr
l'ensemble de l'année s'est pas
complètement sûr que lille occasionne
une baisse féroce si l'enjeu
derrière cette affaire là mais c'est le
plus vraisemblable c'est de faire
repartir la situation comme avant oui il
ya quelque chose que j'ai pas dit tout à
l'heure dans le fait de faire partir des
situations comme avant c'est que c'est
le seul plan qui vient à l'esprit de
tout le monde quand il s'agit de sauver
l'emploi c'est à dire que aujourd'hui
comme on n'a pas le plan pour créer de
l'emploi à la volée avec des
investissements massifs ailleurs que
dans les activités qu'il faut sauver et
que par ailleurs cela supposerait de
former des compétences de les faire
monter et c est que c'est quelque chose
qui est un facteur limitant à court
terme
le seul endroit où on est des
compétences disponibles pour créer
rapidement des emplois qui ont été
supprimés par la crise c'est de refaire
ce qu'on a fait des avancées de refaire
la même chose
or le la principale préoccupation est la
première préoccupation et on ne peut pas
les en blâmer du gouvernement après la
crise ça va être de faire repartir
l'emploi
donc c'est bien pour ça que je disais
tout à l'heure je ne pense pas qu'il va
y avoir une grosse fenêtre de tir pour
faire des choses très différemment cette
fois ci par contre au moment où plan de
relance commencera à caboter là oui il
faudra avoir des choses j'ai envie de
dire prêtes à l'emploi et l'emploi sera
bien le maître bau de la faire c'est
bien ça qui sera au centre des
réflexions de tout le monde
il ya un but de dia discrimination qu'il
faut faire sur la relance post pandémie
dans les pays comme l'europe
enfin dans les autres comme l'europe
pardon qui sont totalement
alors pardon ça dépend si on inclut la
mer du nord qui sont largement je vais
être plus précis dépourvu de pétrole
aujourd'hui la mer du nord c'est un
petit quart de l'approvisionnement
pétrolier européen
donc ça fait pas beaucoup qui sont en
déclin gazier donc la mer du nord c'est
50% d'approvisionnement gazier européen
reste en déclin et qui sont aussi en
déclin charbonnier le déclin charbonnier
en europe a commencé dans les années 60
et
ça ne doit rien au climat dans ces zones
là notre seule capacité de retrouver
rapidement de l'énergie en quantité
importante je dis bien en quantité
importante c'est d'importer du pétrole
importé du gaz de très loin c'est
compliqué parce que ce soit il faut
construire un gazoduc et ça prend dix ou
vingt ans et puis en plus le la russie
se mouche un peu le nez quand il s'agit
de le faire avec nous ils préfèrent le
faire avec le chinois qui sont moins
regardants sur leurs histoires de
politique interne et par par méthaniers
avec du gnl avec du gaz naturel liquéfié
c'est des infrastructures de
liquéfaction qui sont très lourdes et
par ailleurs là pour cette énergie là on
est en concurrence avec toutes les zones
du monde c'est une vraie énergie
mondiale comme pour le pétrole et les
producteurs de gaz naturel liquéfié
préfère les asiatiques qui sont prêts à
payer beaucoup plus cher que les
européens donc on va avoir du mal à
importer rapidement du gaz
on va avoir du mal à apporter rapidement
du charbon parce que le charbon est un
pont d'hérault solide donc c'est un truc
pour lequel la chaîne logistique est
indébordable donc le seul truc qu'on
peut importer rapidement pour faire
repartir l'économie c'est le pétrole
hors du pétrole comme je le disais tout
à l'heure on va avoir un problème
par contre les pays qui ont
domestiquement du gaz et du charbon ce
qui est le cas des états unis ce qui est
le cas de la chine ce qui est le cas de
l'inde pour son charbon
eux ils peuvent très bien effectivement
faire un plan de relance encore plus
charbonneau qu'avant c'est
malheureusement quelque chose qui est
possible donc pour l'europe et pour les
pays qui ont du charbon la situation ne
se présentera pas de la même manière
dans la relance
possible nous je pense que
malheureusement la seule relance qui est
à notre portée c'est la relance de la
décarbonation parce que la physique nous
empêche d'avoir une relance qui
ressemble à autre chose alors est ce que
cette relance de la décarbonation on
peut être de miser massivement sur les
nerfs le grand paradoxe c'est que si on
veut raccourcir les chaînes
d'approvisionnement non l'énergie
renouvelable solaire et l'énergie
renouvelable vent sont effectivement des
énergies locales
par contre leur dispositif de collecte
aujourd'hui ne sont absolument pas
locaux les dix premiers producteurs de
panneaux solaires sont chinois et dans
lé fabricant de nacelles
aujourd'hui vous avez aussi des chinois
en pagaille donc nous sommes aussi
dépendants de l'étranger sur des chaînes
d'approvisionnement très longue
si on décide de développer fortement les
énergies renouvelables sur le
développement qui a déjà eu lieu
donc tout ce qu'on a pris comme
engagement à fin 2010 8 sur l'éolien le
solaire en france
que ce soit des installations déjà
construites ou des installations qu'on
s'est engagée à construire
donc les engagements déjà pris à fin
2010 8 le montant total auxquels ça
correspond pour le pays est de l'ordre
de 120 milliards d'euros
or éolien offshore ses 120 milliards
d'euros seront financés par le
contribuable au travers des taxes sur
l'électricité et puis maintenant des
taxes sur le pétrole est dense et 120
milliards d'euros
j'ai un calcul j'ai fait un calcul du
pouce qui est que de l'ordre de 40
milliards iront alimenter des
industriels chinois
c'est de l'ordre de 40 milliards alors
les ont déjà alimenté où iront les
alimenter plus tard vous voyez bien que
ce système là est un système qui
paradoxalement a besoin d'une économie
très bien portante pour fonctionner dans
une économie qui se porte mal et dans
une économie qui veut re localiser et
bien il ya deux antagonismes qui on voit
apparaître il ya un antagonisme sur la
provenance des panneaux donc il faudrait
faire les panneaux chez nous avec de
l'acier français du cuivre français du
silicium française c'est comme ça c'est
pas prêt il y en a partout
l'acier on en a plus on a pu mieux faire
chez nous le cuivre on en a pas de
cuivre il faut de l'électronique de
puissance pour piloter ce système là ces
systèmes laas ont paradoxalement plus
sophistiqué que le système nucléaire
qu'on voudrait faire baisser parce qu'on
a fait des centrales nucléaires à
l'époque où le monde était analogique
c'est l'époque où le monde
l'époque où il y avait pas
d'informatique et pas de système
numérique on sait faire une centrale
nucléaire dans ces conditions là je ne
sais pas si on sait faire un système
totalement basée sur l'éolien et le
solaire dans un monde dans lequel n'ya
pas d'informatique il n'y a pas de
numérique
y'a pas d'électronique de puissance ce
que j'ai compris en discutant avec les
électriciens c'est que la réponse était
non donc si on veut faire un système
totalement résilient et local local à
l'échelle de la france
j'entends le grand paradoxe c'est que
c'est pas évident que ce soit avec de
l'éolien et du solaire que on va
facilement y arriver c'est pas non plus
un système très résilient c'est
paradoxalement plus facile de faire des
réacteurs nucléaires
parce que de l'acier on peut en recycler
chez nous un petit peu pour faire des
cuves on n'a pas besoin de beaucoup
d'acier alors que pour faire beaucoup d
éoliennes on a besoin de beaucoup
d'acier donc on peut réciter quelques
ferraille chez nous et du radium importé
on peut tenir quelques années avec
aujourd'hui on a des stocks qui permet
de tenir quelques années donc
paradoxalement le nucléaire est un
système plutôt plus résilient du point
de vue de la dépendance aux chaînes
d'approvisionnement longue et à
l'extérieur
alors puisqu'on est sur le nucléaire je
vais aussi prendre les quelques
questions qui concernait cet aspect là
est ce qu'il ya un risque sur le
fonctionnement du parc nucléaire la
réponse est évidemment oui il ya
toujours des risques partout la question
c'est de savoir à quel seuil il se situe
et des f a aujourd'hui un plan qu'on
appelle un plan pandémie dans lequel ils
sont capables de fonctionner plusieurs
semaines avec seulement 60 % des
effectifs et si ma mémoire est bonne de
l'ordre de 15 jours avec 40% des
effectifs
alors qu'est-ce qu'ils font après 6
ça doit durer plus longtemps et que tout
le monde est malade chez eux d'abord la
première bonne nouvelle c'est que la
durée d'incubation du virus est en
quinze jours et la durée de la maladie
et en quinze jours si le personnel et df
est malade et que il a moins de 60 ans
ce qui est généralement le cas dans
cette société où on part à la retraite
beaucoup trop tôt ce qui est un scandale
eh bien il a toutes les chances de ne
plus être malade
au bout d'un mois donc la probabilité
que l'ensemble du personnel et des elfes
soit malade de façon durable sur la
durée de la pandémie avec la virulence
de ce qu'on a aujourd'hui alors ma
réponse ne porte pas sur ce qui se
passerait avec un virus plus méchant
mais avec la virulence de ce qu'on a
aujourd'hui
la bonne nouvelle entre guillemets c'est
que le personnel d'edf ne devrait pas
être malade de façon massive pendant
plus d'un mois la deuxième chose qui
peut se faire
c'est que comme la consommation
électrique est abaissé elle a perdu en
gros 10 gigawatts de puissance appelée
dans la journée quand on regarde les
courbes de rte
on peut se permettre de mettre à l'arrêt
quelques réacteurs et un réacteur à
l'arrêt demande beaucoup moins de monde
que un réacteur en fonctionnement
donc ça c'est une deuxième marche de
manoeuvre que edf peut activer troisième
marge de manoeuvre que élève peut
activer c'est de faire revenir des gens
qui sont des jeunes retraités ou des
gens qui sont des forces de maintenant
il ya une force d'intervention rapide
dans le nucléaire qui est justement
capable de prendre le contrôle de
n'importe quelle centrale si il faut
donc ça ça fait des réserves
supplémentaires
donc si on met tout ça bout à bout c'est
à dire le fait qu'ils peuvent
fonctionner en mode dégradé pendant plus
que la durée d'incubation du virus plus
la durée de la maladie que iliad et de
la réserve et que on peut baisser la
puissance puisque aujourd'hui le pays
fonctionne au ralenti
la réponse à la question c'est que avant
qu'on touche les limites du système
c'est-à-dire qu'on soit obligé de créer
des délestages parce qu'il serait obligé
de mettre en arrêt plus de centrales que
celle qu'ils peuvent faire fonctionner
je pense que là pour le coup il ya
encore de la marge s'est passé par la
crainte première on va dire dans ce qui
se passe j'ai beaucoup plus peur si je
dois livrer un sentiment personnel d'une
situation qui échapperait au pouvoir en
place parce que on impose à la
population des mesures qui vont être
économiquement trop douloureuse pendant
trop longtemps
voilà ça c'est quelque chose qui me
paraît être plus un risque le plus
important que le risque de
fonctionnement dans une entreprise qui
encore une fois elle un plan qui avait
été pensé avant que les emmerdements
arrive après il y avait une deuxième
question sur la fusion alors celle là je
vais là passé parce que c'est pas une
question d'actualité et que pour ceux
d'entre vous qui ne connaissent pas la
réponse la réponse est que vous serez
tous morts tous ceux qui m'écoutent la
même si vous avez des jeunes enfants qui
sont en train de regarder les pôles de
narines
vous serez tous morts que la fusion ne
sera toujours pas une réalité
industrielle
donc on peut passer cette question très
rapidement il ya un dernier point en ce
qui concerne les centrales parce que on
me l'avait déjà posé la dernière fois
mais j'avais pas la réponse
en ce qui concerne le il ya une mesure
ultime en cas de canicule
parce qu'il peut y avoir une canicule
qui revient alors que l'épidémie n'est
pas jugulée il ya une mesure qui a été
imposé aux centrales qui est de faire un
forage profond
à côté de chaque centrale pour avoir de
quoi refroidir le réacteur une fois mis
à l'arrêt comme vous le savez une fois
que réacteurs et mis à l'arrêt ses
terres qu'il ne produit plus il continue
quand même à dégager de la chaleur parce
que les produits de fission qui sont à
l'intérieur du coeur
la décroissance radioactive produit de
l'énergie produit la chaleur
cette chaleur c'est très rapidement
mille fois moins que le réacteur quand
ils fonctionnent à pleine puissance donc
c'est beaucoup moins de chaleur à
évacuer mais c'est suffisant pour faire
fondre le coeur si on évacue pas et
alors pour ça il faut avoir en gros à
gros robin est l'équivalent du débit des
robinets à lui mais ça suffit à évacuer
la chaleur et pour ça les centrales on
créer des forages profonds dans les
nappes à côté des centrales donc même si
le fleuve est à sec
même s'il n'ya pas grand monde dans la
centrale qui est à l'arrêt on a quand
même les moyens de continuer à leur
fournir et donc d'éviter qu'on ait des
emmerdements de ce côté là alors après
il ya une question hors catégorie
pourquoi ne pas créer un film tanks
alors la bonne réponse c'est qu'il
existe se fixe donc c'est très
exactement ce que fait de she project
dechy project réfléchit depuis son
origine à la façon de fonctionner dans
un monde qui doit se décarbonés alors
aujourd'hui on n'a pas toutes les
réponses
par contre ce que je peux vous dire
parce que c'est une décision qui date de
ce matin c'est que on va profiter de la
période actuelle pour essayer de
remettre sur la table une version
actualisée et crache program is et de ce
qu'on avait fait au moment de la
dernière présidentielle qui était donc
les neuf propositions du manifeste pour
décarbonés l'europe
depuis on a travaillé sur d'autres
mesures on a travaillé sur la mobilité
du quotidien on a continué à travailler
sur le bâtiment donc on a on a on a
travaillé sur l'enseignement enfin voilà
on a travaillé sur un certain nombre de
choses sur le numérique
donc on a travaillé sur un certain
nombre de choses qui n'existaient pas à
cette époque là est ce que nous allons
faire c'est que nous allons imaginer
notre propre programme de relance
voilà si j'avais 300 milliards ou si
j'avais 500 milliards comment est-ce
qu'on l'ait dépenserait parce que la
très très bonne nouvelle quand même y en
a une de ce qui vient de se passer
ces derniers jours c'est que l'argent
n'est plus un problème
voilà enfin on découvre que l'argent
on a besoin de 300 milliards on les
trouve on aura besoin de 500 milliards
on les trouvera qu'est ce qui se passe
en ce moment et ça rebondit sur une
autre question qui a été posée qui est
le parallèle entre le coronavirus et le
changement climatique
il ya une énorme différence entre les
deux c'est que la sanction de l'inaction
sur le corona virus elle a lieu à
l'intérieur du mandat présidentiel en
cours
dit autrement si on fait n'importe
la sanction est immédiate on voit les
gens mourir si on ne fait pas n'importe
quoi qui est de laisser les gens mourir
en disant c'est comme ça que ça doit se
passer parce que par ailleurs je veux
sauver l'économie
la sanction est immédiate aussi c'est à
dire que de toute façon quelle que soit
la décision prise
1 la sanction de la décision est
absolument immédiate
le danger est clairement identifié donc
on est capable de lui donner un nom on
est capable de voir à quoi ils
ressemblent on est capable de voir
comment le virus tue du coup on a eu une
idée très claire des contre-mesures on
sait que ça s'appelle des masques alors
on peut discuter du fait que les
contre-mesures sont pas au niveau que
l'on devrait réquisitionné toutes les
entreprises françaises qui fabrique des
chaussettes et des maillots de bain et
leur demander de fabriquer des masques
on peut très bien discuter de ça mais
par contre les contre mesures elles sont
claires elles sont elles sont faciles à
identifier et donc elles sont faciles à
mettre en avant
par ailleurs le dommages immédiats il
est facile à quantifier et donc c'est
facile de mettre en face quelque chose
qui correspond à une situation d'urgence
en ce qui concerne le climat il faut
faire naître le sentiment d'urgence et
il faut le faire naître pour quelque
chose qui ne se voit pas encore
suffisamment pour que ça inquiète les
gens alors ça a commencé à se voir
beaucoup plus quand même les deux
canicule convient de se prendre en 2018
et 2019 ont clairement fait monter le
sujet en pression le fait que les jeunes
bougent un peu ça fait monter deux
sujets en pression le fait que
l'australie viennent de perdre
l'équivalent de la moitié de la
superficie française lors de ces
incendies
et ce n'est peut-être pas terminée fait
monter le sujet en pression mais tout ça
n'est toujours pas considéré comme étant
un risque vital de court terme
exactement comme le corona virus donc
l'un des enjeux de la période actuelle
aussi c'est d'arriver à faire comprendre
que
on est aussi face à la menace climat et
à la menace énergétique parce que tout
ça se conjugue et puis en plus las manos
de diversité et qu' on est face à
l'urgence
voilà c'est ça c'est ça le grand défi et
que l'on doit être face à une urgence
mobilisatrice donc pour reprendre les
mots de petter solberg ait eu de panique
en fait c'est à you want you turiaf qui
devrait être la bonne expression parce
que paniqués est un mouvement désordonné
paniqué est un mouvement dans lequel
vous marcher sur la tête du voisin pour
sortir du cinéma en feu avant lui alors
que ce dont on a besoin c'est pas de
panique et on a besoin de réagir et pour
réagir
il est absolument indispensable que l'on
ait une idée claire de ce à quoi on est
confronté donc un des enjeux aussi de la
période actuelle c'est que on va essayer
où il faudrait essayer de faire monter
la compréhension du problème traité en
face enfin dans l'esprit des classes
dirigeantes donc il ya un gros enjeu de
formation et peut-être qu'une voix qui
est offerte par ce qui est en train de
se passer en ce moment c'est le fait que
notre président n'est pas arrêté de
prononcer le mot scientifique dans sa
2ème allocution à la nation
et peut-être que la voix qui aujourd'hui
la voie étroite qui se dessine c'est que
dès qu'il retrouvera son souffle on lui
colle l'obligation de prendre quelques
heures de cours c'est à dire d'écouter
les scientifiques là aussi alors de les
écouter à la fois dans le domaine
climatique et dans le domaine
énergétique dans le domaine énergétique
s'est pas vraiment des scientifiques
c'est plutôt des sachants on va dire
pour que le sentiment d'urgence qui fait
que les cordons de la bourse ont
s'ouvrir naissent également
dans ce domaine là ou plus exactement on
voyait des deux c'est à dire que le plan
de relance soit le plus d'écart bonnan
possible et que si ce plan de relance
n'est pas d'écart bonnan le plus vite
possible
on passe sur quelque chose qui le soit
vraiment voilà donc le parallèle entre
le coronavirus et le changement
climatique c'est l'échelle de temps
c'est la visibilité des conséquences
c'est le fait que la réponse ne souffre
pas de discussion si on veut répondre
en d'autres termes on pourrait dire bah
l'époque vaussard donc les vieux
mourront et puis voilà et le reste du
pays continuent à vivre normalement
mais à partir du moment où on décide de
répondre on ne peut pas répondre
autrement que avec les mesures qui sont
faciles à voir le débat sur ce qu'il
faut faire en matière de changements
climatiques qui continue à y avoir des
débats en matière de mobilité les uns
vous dis il faut tout miser sur la
voiture électrique tedo que vous dites
non faut pas de voiture électrique faut
des vélos les troisièmes vous dise non
il vaudrait mieux des trains
les quatrièmes vous disent il vaut mieux
des bus et les cinquièmes vous dise vaut
mieux s'attaquer d'abord à l'aérien et
les sixièmes vous dise d'abord il faut
mieux s'attaquer à la mobilité du
quotidien donc c'est plus compliqué
aussi parce que les mesures à mettre en
place continue à faire l'objet de débats
qui ne seront jamais totalement tranché
un moment où il faut décider il n'y a
pas de ya pas de l'algorithme qui
permettent de dire c'est absolument
certain que c'est ça qu'il faut faire
donc le jeu j'ai envie de dire le
l'élément intéresser les deux éléments
intéressants issu de l'expérience
actuelle et dont j'espère qu'ils vont
resservir
quand la tempête actuelle ce sera un peu
calmée et que on passera à l'étape
d'après et que donc après s'être occupé
des vieux pour continuer dans la
provocation on s'occupera des jeunes
eh bien ces deux c'est à la fois
d'essayer de renforcer la compréhension
du problème à traiter au sein du monde
politique et au sein du monde économique
et par ailleurs de rester sur cette idée
que à partir du moment où on a un plan
déterminé l'argent n'est pas un problème
et de fait à partir du moment où on a un
plan déterminé l'argent n'est pas un
problème ce qui va se passer avec cette
création monétaire massive ou avec cette
aide massive
c'est en fait une forme d'inflation
voilà c'est à dire que l'ensemble de la
collectivité assumera les forts avec de
l'inflation bon bah c'est pas très grave
les taux négatifs c'est une autre forme
d'inflation s'est pas donc donc ça c'est
ça qui va se passer et donc y aura une
érosion patrimoniale mais encore une
fois là pour le coup c'est quelque chose
que je trouve normal même si je suis du
mauvais côté de la barrière
c'est quelque chose que je trouve normal
l'érosion patrimoniale revient à faire
un transfert des vieux en faveur des
jeunes
c'est à dire depuis ce qu'ont bien
profiter en faveur de ceux pour qui la
vie reste à écrire
donc je trouve pas ça anormal je trouve
même ça prévient green deal européen
puisque nous sommes dans les plans de
relance
alors j'en ai déjà un peu parlé du green
deal européen où j'ai dit il est il
s'inscrit dans le cadre d'un monde en
croissance on a parlé de 1000 milliards
alors mille milliards c'est à peu près
ce qu'on a déjà mis sur la table pour
faire l'électricité renouvelable à base
d'éolien et de solaire qu'on a déjà fait
en europe
voilà c'est 5000 milliards est ce que ça
a changé fondamentalement la structure
des villes non est ce que ça a changé
fondamentalement la structure de
l'agriculture non est ce que ça a changé
fondamentalement
structure de l'industrie non ce que ça
va changer fondamentalement les
bâtiments dans lesquels on habite dont
est ce que ça a changé fondamentalement
la production électrique au charbon même
pas donc c'est une goutte d'eau donc
1000 milliards face à ce qu'il faut
faire c'est c'est très bien autant les
prendre mais ça ne changera pas grand
chose à ce que nous devons faire
donc ce que nous devons faire dans une
europe qui fait un peu plus de dix mille
milliards de pib par an c'est pas 1000
milliards s'est on doit réorienter 3000
ou 4000 milliards de pib par an dit
autrement dans le pib européen
il y en a 30 40 ou 50% qui en l'espace
de quelques années doit se mettre à
faire autre chose que ce qu'il fait
c'est ça l'enjeu et ça ça nécessite pas
nécessaire enfin ça nécessite pas
obligatoirement pardon d d d injection
directe de capitaux une bonne
réglementation peut être tout aussi
efficace et à ce moment il faut juste
aider les investissements des opérateurs
privés qui vont devoir faire je prends
un exemple le bâtiment en france
ma conviction profonde c'est que la
rénovation du bâtiment en france doit se
faire à la charge des propriétaires on
peut faire un rapide calcul d'ordre de
grandeur
vous avez en france 30 millions de
foyers un foyer un logement qui en
moyenne fait 80 mètres carrés
allez mettons sens pour faire des choses
simples donc vous avez 3 milliards de
mètre carré en france
une rénovation un peu lourde coûte 1000
euros du mètre carré même 500 on est en
train de parler de 1500 à 3000 milliards
d'euros il est évident qu'on va pas
faire des subventions publiques pour
1500 à 3000 milliards d'euros donc c'est
les propriétaires qui vont devoir faire
donc on oblige les propriétaires à faire
aujourd'hui les propriétaires dépense 50
milliards d'euros dans les travaux chez
eux donc le simple fait d'orienter la
totalité de ces travaux
d'embarquer plus exactement la
performance thermique dans la totalité
de ces travaux tout de suite
en cinquante ans ça vous fait 2500
milliards d'euros et qu'on n'était pas
trop trouve un désordre de vendeurs et
pour ça une bonne réglementation suffit
la réglementation c'est de dire vous
allez être obligé de faire ça
et du coup les gens ils font moins
d'extension de pavillons et moins de
réflexion de salle de bains et ils font
plus de travaux de traitement thermique
du bâtiment voilà donc c'est quelque
chose qui se gère et d'une manière
générale
aujourd'hui l'europe un green deal qui
est vu comme étant j'investis dans des
techno donc je vais investir dans les
éoliennes je vais investir dans des
voitures électriques je vais investir
dans des batteries je vais investir dans
ceci cela je ne pense pas que le green
deal européen c'est je vais investir
dans de la voirie cyclable canton
réouvrira les routes françaises à la
circulation et blanc ce moment là y'a
pas un km de bouchons en ile de france
j'ai fait de petites blagues et deux
jours en disant c'est parfait au moment
où henry ou à la circulation il ya qu'a
décidé overnight là qu'un quart de la
voirie est réservée aux vélos
bon bah ça c'est quelque chose qui ne
demandent aucun investissement giroud sa
demande juste une décision donc le don
qu'il ya des tas de mesures pour
lesquelles en fait c'est pas encore une
fois un problème de plans
d'investissement qui est la question la
question c'est le la décision de la
direction qu'on qu'on décide de prendre
alors je suis un peu caricaturale dans
ce que je viens de dire parce que si on
disait il ya les trois quarts de la
voirie pour les voitures et un quart
pour les vélos il ya des gens qui
pourrait plus servir de leur voiture ou
plus difficilement du coup ils
chercheraient à la vendre comme beaucoup
de gens chercheraient à l'avant on
dirait une dépréciation du capital et
l'arrêt semblablement il faudrait aider
les gens modestes qui se retrouve avec
une bagnole qui peuvent moins facilement
utiliser et qui ne peuvent pas vendre
donc il ya quand même un moment des
besoins d'investissement c'est
absolument évident mais ce que je veux
dire c'est que le green deal vu sous
l'angle des techno je pense qu'il fait
fausse route
il faut faire le green deal vu sous
l'angle de l'organisation et pour le
moment c'est pas du tout ce qui va se
passer
l'europe je pense va aussi essayer
quelque chose qui va ne pas produire les
effets escomptés
ça sera essentiellement du 'business as
usual' dans un monde qui par ailleurs
est comment dire qui doit qui doit
retrouver la croissance structurelle de
long terme puisque vous savez bien que
c'est ça notre projet pour l'avenir
alors qu'est ce que je vais prendre
maintenant
allez un p'tit coup d'effondrement
systémique qu'un donc est-ce que nous
sommes au début de l' effondrement
systémique
je ne pense pas que ce soit lyon au
début je pense que nous sommes en cours
d'effondrement systémique ce que je
pense aussi mais ça ça fait longtemps
que je le pense c'est que je ne crois
pas que cet effondrement systémique va
se passer en 24 heures ou en tout cas
c'est pas l'éventualité la plus probable
bien sûr qu'il ya des modalités avec
l'en 24 heures par exemple monsieur tron
pâte rappelé coronavirus ça le rend fou
il appuie sur le bouton nucléaire
voilà ça c'est effectivement c'est un
truc qui peut il peut se produire
et alors là pour le coup ça crée des
destructions beaucoup plus violente mais
hors épisode de cette nature je pense
que l' effondrement systémique a
commencé parce que la biodiversité a
commencé à s'éroder
parce que notre capital naturel a
commencé à être entamées et le fait que
le pib continue à augmenter et que la
population continue à augmenter ne doit
pas nous tromper
si l'effondrement c'est l'incapacité du
système à se reconstituer sur ses bases
peut-être que nous avons dépassé le
point si cher à mes doses de la
possibilité d'une stabilisation
c'est à dire que même si on arrêtait la
population à son niveau actuel
et même si on arrêtait le pib à son
niveau actuel
en fait on est au delà et très au delà
de la capacité de récupération
de là des écosystèmes tels qu'ils sont
et donc de toutes façons cela continue à
se dégrader puis la population à un
moment on va se mettre à baisser de
toute façon qu'on le veuille ou pas et
la production physique aussi donc le
donc le l'effondrement je pense que il a
un petit feu commençait maintenant
l'effondrement ça peut prendre très
longtemps un effondrement ça peut
prendre un siècle
l'effondrement de l'empiré romain a été
lent on parie le plus vraisemblable sur
l'effondrement c'est que c'est un
processus qui est un processus par
marche d'escalier
c'était un peu de temps en temps je
prends une marche d'escalier et là on
vient de s'en prendre une petite de
marche d'escalier derrière laquelle on
reviendra pas exactement au niveau
précédent
voilà je les dis sur le pétrole et ils
effondrement est un processus qui va par
par marche d'escalier
[Musique]
question comment est ce qu'on fait pour
naviguer dans un univers comme ça si on
revient à des choses un peu pragmatique
et bien je le leur dis il faut faire une
analyse par scénario je vois mal comment
est ce que on peut faire autrement c'est
à dire qu'il faut jouer à un jeu de 6
alors sur pleins d'éventualités possible
et essayer de voir tout un tas de choses
qui pourraient se produire et comment
est-ce qu'on réagit en pareil cas ce qui
me paraît à peu près évident c'est que
par contre nous avons une capacité à
partir du moment où ça se passe dans un
contexte dans lequel le les gens sont
d'accord pour rester constructif ce qui
est tout le sujet nous avons une grosse
marge sur la capacité à perdre une
partie de ce que nous avons aujourd'hui
et je pense que là l'une des
caractéristiques intéressantes de la
perte de liberté que nous avons en ce
moment c'est qu'elle est égalitaire dit
autrement riche ou pauvre jane ou vieux
de toute façon les gens sont priés de
rester chez eux
des riches ont pas plus que les pauvres
la possibilité de rouler carrosse et de
se balader partout alors ils ont un peu
fait pour les parisiens qui sont partis
dans leur résidence secondaire
ça a été très mal vu probablement à
juste titre mais pour ceux qui n'ont pas
fait ça et bien le la mesure est
extrêmement égalitaire et je pense que
c'est une des raisons pour lesquelles
elle est bien accepté paradoxalement les
gens gueulent - contre ce qui est en
train de se passer en ce moment que il
engueulait contre la taxe carbone qui
était quand même une mesure beaucoup
plus indolore en fait quand on y pense
donc le don pour en revenir à la
question sur l'effondrement oui je crois
que l'effondrement et et a commencé
je ne crois pas que cela veuille dire
que tout est foutu qu'il n'y a pas moyen
de faire des plans pour l'avenir et
qu'il faut baisser les bras
c'est pas ça que je crois je crois que
la lente érosion du système est en route
oui et message après rien à personne en
disant que c'est le cas dans les marches
d'escalier
donc il faut à mon avis se méfiait très
fortement et ça aussi pour moi c'est un
risque plus important que le risque
nucléaire
c'est le risque de fermeture brutale des
frontières alors je ne suis pas le plus
grand partisan qui soit de la
mondialisation et ses terres que je
pense qu'on est allé beaucoup trop loin
dans cette direction et qu'on a c'est ce
que j'ai tout à l'heure beaucoup trop
allonger les chaînes d'approvisionnement
beaucoup trop entre guillemets
délocaliser ou plus exactement fait des
trucs chez les autres qu'on n'aurait
jamais fait chez soi
par contre ce qu'il faudrait éviter
c'est que la tentation nationaliste
rampante et qu'il est pas due aux
coronavirus s'exprime à plein à la
faveur de ce qui est en train de se
passer est qu'on assiste très
brutalement à une émergence
comment dire nationaliste très forte et
qui derrière crée des tensions qui
déboucheront sur des conflits voilà ça
c'est quelque chose dont il faut se
méfier comme de la peste
parce que je suis pas complètement sûr
que la guerre soit largement préférable
à la récession ou même la maladie donc
le en tout cas la maladie au niveau
auquel elle est actuellement donc le le
le
le sujet de la fermeture brutale et du
repli brutal sur soi dans le cadre de ce
qui est en train de se passer est à mon
avis une tentation dont il faut se
défier et je considère à ce titre que le
terme d'autonomie énergétique qui a été
mis en avant par un certain nombre
d'élus locaux est un terme qui de ce
point de vue est un terme dangereux
parce que l'autonomie celle inverse de
la collaboration et je crois c'est le
truc intéressant que j'ai retiré des
lectures de l'ami serving que dans les
temps difficiles la porte de sortie
c'est la collaboration et ce n'est pas
le repli sur soi c'est la collaboration
bon sens du terme celle entraide et
c'est pas du tout le repli sur soi et
donc le fait d'être inséré dans une
communauté est important alors que on
essaye de ralentir les échanges mondiaux
oui je suis premier partisan que l'on
parle d'autonomie au sens de j'ai plus
besoin des autres je me suffis à moi
même je pense que ça c'est un piège
mortel
et c'est pas pour rien que l'europe a
été basée sur les échanges
donc là on est allé jusqu'à la nausée
mais quelques échanges sont absolument
indispensables parce qu'il faut être
capable de coopérer et de collaborer et
d'avoir besoin de l'autre avant donc le
il faut se sortir cette expression de la
tête l'autonomie énergétique
il faut une forme de résilience
énergétique ça c'est absolument évident
donc la résilience oui mais dire je veux
répit sur moi j'ai plus besoin des
autres je pense que c'est quelque chose
qui est dangereux dans un climat à
déstabiliser
est-ce que la situation mondiale et
modélisable par un modèle mathématique
ou physique
et bien si on relit les modélisations de
l'équipe meadows dans les miz griffe les
limites à la croissance on se rend
compte que la réponse est oui de façon
macroscopique non de façon microscopique
c'est à dire que personne ne saura vous
dire la prochaine marche d'escalier
viendra de tels endroits et le coup
qu'on va prendre sur la calebasse
viendra de tels endroits et ce sera du
at-elle factor ça c'est évident que
c'est ça va pas se produire
par contre le fait de dire le fait de
pouvoir prédire de façon précise quelque
chose donc non le fait de dire
globalement comment ça va évoluer la wii
malheureusement les simulations qui
avait été fait il ya 40 ans sont pas si
mauvaise que ça
de ce point de vue est ce qu'il ya un
risque de pénurie alimentaire dans le
monde aujourd'hui je ne crois pas parce
que quelque chose qui est facile à faire
c'est de réquisitionner de la main
d'oeuvre pour aller arracher les pommes
de terre
même si les gens enfin voilà donc je
pense que la réponse là et non la
pénurie alimentaire elle arrive quand
les circuits de transport sont
totalement disrupt et et des circuits de
transport totalement district et
arriverait si on avait une pénurie en
pétrole donc aujourd'hui la pénurie
alimentaire elle arriverait avec la
pénurie de pétrole
il n'y a pas de risque de pénurie de
pétrole à très court terme parce qu'
aucun pays aujourd'hui n'a dit qu'au
titre du coronavirus il allait supprimer
l'approvisionnement pétrolier en fait
c'est plutôt l'inversé a pour le moment
1 avec 7 pétrole donc la pénurie
alimentaire non pas à court terme
pas à cause de ce qui est en train de se
passer ça c'est sûr à plus long terme
avec le climat je pense pas non plus
qu'en france il ya un risque de pénurie
alimentaire majeure
enfin tout cas pas dans les décennies
qui viennent par contre un risque d'
augmentation très forte du prix de la
nourriture et de diminuer et de
diminution très forte de la part carnet
dans l'alimentation ça oui parce que ça
serait la conséquence logique de la
baisse des rendements agricoles
mais tant qu'il poussera encore trois
trucs voilà normalement on a de la marge
la de ce point de vue parce que
l'essentiel de la production serrano et
des animaux et donc là on a encore de la
marge
de ce point de vue alors qu'est ce que
je vais pouvoir prendre maintenant comme
[Musique]
poum poum poum poum 1
à quoi ressemblera mon quotidien si je
veux rester sous les deux degrés par
rapport à ce que je vis sur le colis de
19 à ça c'est une question intéressante
et bien en perdre de consommation
matérielle
je pense que là on vient d'avoir un très
bon avant goûter à tous les magasins
sont fermés
alors bon il reste amazon mais sinon
tous les magasins sont fermés donc
instantanément nous ne pouvons plus rien
acheter dans le monde qui veut où on
reste sous les deux degrés c'est évident
que la production industrielle baisse
fortement
donc on aura moins de choses à se mettre
sous la dent on aura moins facilement la
possibilité de prendre l'avion donc ça
c'est très illustrative en fait on en
aura plus donc ça ce qui est en train de
se passer en ce moment sur l'avion est
très illustratif aussi de ce qui va se
passer sur ce plan là bon on est en
train de sortir de la saison de
chauffage
donc là il ya pas tellement d'éléments à
donner sur ce plan là est par contre un
autre élément qui est intéressant c'est
que comme on l'a dit un certain nombre
de fois pour rester sous les deux degrés
il faudrait qu'à l'échelle mondiale
il y ait une réorientation très rapide
des activités économiques donc il y aura
des mesures autoritaires alors pas aussi
violent entre la restriction de
circulation qu'on a en ce moment mais y
aura des mesures autoritaires qui
devront être prises et qui contraindront
un peu plus que ce qu'on avait
l'habitude de voir comme la normalité
il y encore dix jours voilà donc ce ne
seront pas les mêmes sommes les mêmes
contraintes que celle qu'on a
aujourd'hui
mais il ya des éléments sur lesquels on
peut réfléchir à partir de ce qui est en
train de se passer aujourd'hui
[Musique]
alors à ont retourné sur la question du
projet politique
est-ce qu'on ne manque pas d'un discours
commun et rassembleur émis par une union
sacrée de différentes personnalités en
fait ça renvoie la question des think
tanks
ça renvoie à la la à la question du
projet politique la réponse est oui
maintenant il ya quelque chose dont il
faut se méfier c'est l'effet de
communauté une bonne partie des gens qui
sont en train de m'écouter appartiennent
de fait à une communauté qui passent
beaucoup de temps à regarder ce que font
les autres membres de la communauté
moi je fais j'ai chaque pas je passe une
bonne partie de la journée à regarder ce
qui se passe au niveau de l'énergie du
climat à interagir avec des gens qui
sont dans mon entreprise ou dans hot
chip project et donc des gens qui entre
guillemets me ressemble alors c'est très
dangereux
parfois c'est pas dangereux c'est
quelque chose qui a un effet de bord
très important c'est que ça fait croire
parce que nous sommes des animaux piloté
par nos sens que le monde entier pense
comme nous or je ne sais pas je pense
que dans les discours rassembleurs qui
peuvent être émis aujourd'hui il y en a
d'autres qui ne ressemble pas du tout à
celui qu'ont en tête les gens qui sont
en train de me regarder où une bonne
partie des gens qui sont en train de
regarder par exemple je pense pour
revenir à un propos que j'ai donné juste
avant que malheureusement le discours
rassembleur nationaliste bas gagné en
amplitude va gagner en ampleur va gagner
en puissance
dans les semaines qui vont venir je suis
pas complètement certain que ce soit un
discours totalement rassembleur au sens
où nous on l'entend il ya un discours
rassembleur qui va avoir lieu qui est
sauver l'emploi et donc sauver des
compagnies aériennes sauver d'efforts de
plus de chez lloyd sauver les
constructeurs automobiles qui font des
suv etc c'est évident qu'on va entendre
ce genre de truc aussi et ça sera vue
pour une bonne partie de la population
comme un discours tout à fait commun et
rassembleur donc plutôt que d'un
discours
moi j'ai envie de dire que on manque
surtout aujourd'hui d'un projet porté
par l'exécutif qui ferait la part des
choses et qui serait capable de proposer
ce que nous pouvons faire de meilleurs
on ne n'y en pas la contrainte avec
laquelle nous allons devoir composer
donc ça ça renvoie à ce que je disais
tout à l'heure pour ceux d'entre vous
qui l'ont lu alors il faut que cette
interview a été faite il ya un mois
quasiment donc c'était fin février
c'était un peu avant que la plaisanterie
actuel de commence mais j'ai donné une
interview au point et la fin de mon
interview était de dire qu'aujourd'hui
alors aujourd'hui c'était fin février
jusqu'à fin février pour être plus
précis on avait des dirigeants qui nous
tenait un discours de boutiquiers c'est
à dire que l'on s'occupait du déficit
budgétaire en s'occuper de la réforme
des retraites en anglais donc tous à ses
discours avec moi que j'appelle de
boutiquiers
c'est le discours que vous tient le
directeur financier dans une entreprise
encore le directeur financier dans une
entreprise c'est monsieur casse couilles
c'est le type qui vous dit où madame ne
reste qu est-ce qu oui c'est qu'il vous
dit je ne peux pas faire ceci je ne peux
pas faire cela on n'a pas l'argent on
n'a pas le budget l'année faut faire
attention à ceux ci fait économiser des
charges là c'est pas un discours de
projet s'est jamais un discours de
projets un discours de directeur
financier c'est très bien qui était
directeur financier disconvient pas mais
le projet n'est jamais chez eux et quand
vous avez un directeur financier qui
devient président de la république et
qui nous dit faut faire gaffe aux
déficits budgétaires faut faire gaffe
aux retraites fo caf etc
c'est un discours de boutiquiers c'est
un truc qui n'intéresse personne sauf
les gens qui sont à l'abri de tout mais
les autres ne les intéresse pas vraiment
donc le
donc le sujet aujourd'hui
sssa l'opportunité on en revient à la
question qui avait le plus intéressé les
gens qui ont imposé le est-ce qu'on va
être capable de passer d'un discours de
boutiques et à un discours de projet et
est ce que ce discours de projet va être
articulé avec on va dire une forme
d'optimisme collectif c'est-à-dire ce
qui garantit à la collectivité le
maximum de bonheur
si tant est qu'on sache comment ça se
mesure c'est ça le c'est ça le point
pour moi alors aujourd'hui le terreau au
sein du gouvernement en termes de
connaissances sur ce qui fait le monde
n'est pas suffisant pour qu'on ait le
projet qui intéresse une bonne partie
des gens qui écoutent c'est à dire
quelque chose qui inclut la
décarbonation de l'économie voire qui
s'articule autour de la décarbonation de
l'économie qui en compte 10 c'est ça
notre projet est donc on va en fonction
de ça enseigner ceci est pas seul à
réformer la fiscalité comme ceux ci est
pas comme seul à payer
préférentiellement les gens qui font tel
métier et un peu moins les gens qui sont
l autre à voir tel type de dialogue avec
nos voisins et pâtai le trip de tel
autre type de dialogue développer tel
type de production et affaiblir tel type
de production organiser le territoire
comme ceux ci plutôt que de l'organiser
comme cela se déplacer comme ceux ci
plutôt que des déplacés comme cela vous
voyez que on est capable de d'articuler
un programme politique complet autour de
ce genre de autour de ce genre de sujet
donc personnellement et après avoir bien
retourner problème dans tous les sens il
me semble que c'est le projet qui est
capable de faire sens dans le monde
auxquelles nous allons devoir faire face
ce projet est aussi capable à l'évidence
d'embarquer la problématique
biodiversité
il est aussi capable d'embarquer la
problématique ce qu'au fond c'est une
approche physique
la problématique ressources et que par
ailleurs l'énergie c'est la capacité
d'accéder à n'importe quoi puisque
l'énergie c'est la transformation par
définition l'énergie c'est la capacité
d'accéder à n'importe quoi quand vous
regardez de physique un don quand vous
regardez le problème sous l'angle
énergétique en fait vous avez accès à
tous les flux physiques qui permettent
au monde de fonctionner tel qu'il
fonctionne
et donc vous avez accès vous avez sur
votre écran radar la totalité des
contraintes avec lesquelles vous devez
composer donc le discours en question je
pense et nous pensons o'shea project et
aussi d'une certaine manière un quart 24
que la décarbonation de l'économie a ce
potentiel maintenant et c'est à ça qu'on
va s'atteler dans les mois qui viennent
au chic project a essayé de faire de
faire monter ce projet de la comme étant
le projet de relance qui a du sens alors
une fois qu'on a dit ça on n'a pas tout
dit hein qu'est ce que je dis à très
court terme aux gens qui bossent chez
air france c'est ce que je leur dis ça
va bien pour cette fois je vous somme je
vous sauve à 80 je vous soumets 90% joue
sauve à 70 vous sauve à 60
je vous sauve pas du tout et demain
matin vous partez en formation pour
devenir chauffeur de bus voilà qu'est ce
qu'on leur dit donc ça résout pas encore
tous les problèmes mais par contre en
terme d'accès structure il me semble que
c'est ce que nous avons de mieux à nous
mettre sous la dent et par ailleurs
c'est une grosse opportunité c'est aussi
avec ça que j'ai fini mon entretien au
point c'est une grosse opportunité pour
notre pays parce que notre pays est
plutôt pas mauvais dans la gestion des
problèmes difficiles
et là nous avons affaire un problème
particulièrement difficile donc c'est
plutôt pour moi une opportunité plutôt
qu'une plutôt qu'une difficulté
voilà donc je mets mes jeux rebondir un
jeu revient sur le début de cette longue
réponse il faut bien se mettre à la
place de tous les gens pour qui
aujourd'hui le climat c'est vraiment pas
le sujet je pense que tous les gens qui
sont aujourd'hui confiné dans des petits
appartements avec des gosses qui
braillent dans la proche couronne
parisienne et avec qui était jeu
pourquoi serveur dans un
dans un restaurant je pense qu'en ce
moment ils sont très très très loin de
cette préoccupation est donc il faut que
ce discours soit capable de les
embarquer et de leur faire comprendre en
quoi ce projet là leur donne une place
et leur donne une place qu'ils
considéreront indésirables voilà c'est
ça la vraie difficulté de ce genre de
discours rassembleur il suffit pas de
séduire les bobos csp + comme moi ça
c'est facile il faut être capable
d'avoir des choses concrètes à dire à
tous les gens qui aujourd'hui sont en
phase de stress croissante alors qu'est
ce que je peux encore trouvé dans cette
assise une question intéressante sur la
théorie du complot parce que la supposée
moi même le coronavirus est il une
excuse idéal pour justifier
l'effondrement financier déjà présents
depuis des mois s organisé par qui alors
je ne crois pas qu'il soit organisé
ça j'y crois pas je crois pas qu'il ya
un beauf elle de quelque part qui est
distribué des petites boîtes de virus à
de charmantes jeunes filles il a comme
l'un des premiers james bond
par contre ce que je crois c'est que il
arrive bien si on peut dire
dit autrement quand on regardait les
signaux faibles de ce qui était en train
de se passer sur l'économie mondiale
depuis deux mois
depuis deux ans pardon je le redis
la production de pétrole est passé par
un maximum historique en novembre 2018
à date elle n'était pas elle était en
train de décroître depuis
[Musique]
et comme vous le savez c'est un facteur
limitant pour l'économie on était en
train de voir les taux négatifs se
multiplier c'était vraiment territoire
inconnu pour pour l'économie la
production industrielle d'un certain
nombre de pays dont l'allemagne
notamment était en train de ralentir
bref on était en train d'assister à un
certain nombre de signes avant coureurs
qu'eux on était bien parti pour avoir de
nouveau quelque chose qui allait se
passer de travers et alors il se trouve
que là dessus arrive le corps navires us
je le redis je ne crois pas une seconde
qu'il ya un complot derrière tout ça par
contre de me dire que le fait qu'il
arrive maintenant va être un soupir de
soulagement pour un certain nombre de
gens qui du coup pourront mettre les
troubles économiques sur le virus
au lieu de le mettre sur autre chose que
la population leur aurait reproché de ne
pas avoir su gérer
je pense qu'en l'occurrence au fond je
n'ai pas complètement sûr que maintenant
soit très triste je je je vois là je
suis pas dans sa tête mais il vient de
faire 35 millions de téléspectateurs
avec un discours un peu martial qui se
situe dans la droite ligne de sa prise
de fonction quand il a marché sol vers
l'estrade au louvre il vient de se poser
en chef de guerre
alors que l'avant ils étaient traités
dans la fin il était traîné dans la
fange parce qu'il était un foutu de
faire revenir soucier cela donc je suis
pas complètement persuadés tout le monde
soit totalement comment dire désespérée
qu' il soit là voilà mais encore une
fois je ne crois pas une seconde à la
théorie du à la théorie du complot
alors j'ai déjà traité traité traiter ça
je peux répondre comment imaginez-vous
l'évolution de la situation sur l'année
2020 imprévisible voilà ça c'est voilà
[Musique]
géopolitique tiens on va parler un peu
de géopolitique
parce que dans le pétrole il ya une
question qui n'a pas été posée mais moi
je vais vous la posez cas pas je vais
répondre comme ça c'est sympa fait
montre entre menu qui est que va-t-il se
passer ailleurs dans le monde
indépendamment du coronavirus avec un
truc que le corps avait un virus masquer
un peu à l'étranger parce qu'on est très
centré sur nos projets domestiques qui
est l'effondrement du prix du pétrole le
pétrole comme vous le savez fait vivre
un certain nombre de pays exportateurs
pour qui ils représentent une fraction
très significative des recettes
budgétaires et donc de la capacité à
assurer de la redistribution il ya des
graphiques qui circulent en ce moment
par exemple sur le prix auquel les pays
exportateurs équilibrer leur budget un
certain nombre de pays du moyen-orient
n'équilibre pas leurs budgets avec un
pétrole en dessous de mémoire 80 dollars
le baril
donc ça veut dire que à ce moment là si
le pétrole reste durablement à 20 ou 30
dollars le baril
il continue à gagner techniquement de
l'argent sur la production du pétrole
il faut savoir que en arabie saoudite
extraire un baril de terre encore
aujourd'hui ses 10 dollars en russie
c'est pas très au dessus donc le on y
rendait aussi dans ces eaux là
donc il ya plein d'endroits dans lequel
à 30 dollars le baril on continue à
gagner techniquement de l'argent chez
l'opérateur pétrolier par contre l'état
qui prélève une rente au passage parce
que à 80 dollars le baril c'est pas du
coup techniques de production vous payez
c'est déjà pour l'essentiel une rente
versée aux pays producteurs plus la
rente versée à l'opérateur pétrolier
mais c'est surtout aux pays producteurs
et bien cette rente disparaît à 20 ou 30
$ alors à ce moment là capacité
redistributive du pays disparaît et si
le pays n'est pas autosuffisants donc on
revient sur les histoires d'autonomie
mais à l'échelle d'un pays cette fois ci
sur l'alimentation et bien ils
commencent à avoir un vrai problème pour
nourrir sa population
c'est très exactement pour cela que se
sont déclenchées ce qu'on a appelé
printemps arabe en 2011 où l'egypte et
la tunisie qui sont des gros
importateurs de nourriture ont été
incapables de faire face aux prix des
aliments qui avaient augmenté très
fortement en 2010 alors que dans le même
temps leurs recettes à l'exportation qui
elle était essentiellement basée sur le
tourisme à bbc
enfin pas essentiellement avait été
largement passé base et pardon sur le
tourisme avait avait laissé reçu pour la
tunisie c'est essentiellement en ce qui
concerne le la situation actuelle c'est
un peu différent parce qu'à l'époque du
printemps arabe
le prix de la nourriture avaient monté
mais il avait monté en même temps que le
prix du pétrole parce que les deux sont
pas servis en général du coup
les pays pétroliers qui importe leur
nourriture aussi l'algérie notamment et
bien au moment où la nourriture coûte
plus cher le pétrole et vendus plus
chers et donc ils peuvent équilibrer les
importations croissantes avec des
exportations croissante et il arrive
qu'ils continuent à nourrir la
population
aujourd'hui avec un prix du pétrole qui
s'effondre il faudra regarder comment
vont évoluer comment va évoluer la
capacité à faire face à des importations
alimentaires des pays qui en sont
dépendants par exemple les pays du golfe
sont dépendants des importations
alimentaires malgré quelques forages
dans les nappes profondes et quelques
faire au milieu du désert ils
nourrissent quand même pas avec ce qui
pousse sur place c'est aussi le cas du
venezuela par exemple qui a connu une
crise profonde
la russie à un tiers de son pib qui
dépend des hydrocarbures alors c'est un
pays qui est tenu c'est pas un pays qui
a des problèmes massifs d'autosuffisance
alimentaire mais il fallait vraiment pas
mais voilà il va falloir voir ce que ça
donne donc la baisse durable du prix du
pétrole parce que le coran navires us
fin quand même impact et les économies
occidentales
grosse consommatrice de pétrole pendant
des mois et comme je le disais tout à
l'heure sur l'ensemble de l'année on va
avoir une récession c'est à peu près
évident va avoir une récession sur
l'ensemble de l'europe
on va avoir une récession aux états unis
tout ça commence à faire beaucoup
et peut-être même une récession en chine
donc tout ça commence à faire beaucoup
et donc le prix du pétrole il est quand
même pas près de se redresser à mon avis
enfin en tout cas pas dans les
circonstances actuelles
donc il ya un vrai sujet qui est à
regarder de très près qui est la
déstabilisation dans ces pays là qui par
ailleurs sont tenues avec delarue
distribution parce que c'est aussi des
pays dans lesquels vous avez des
cohabitation religieuse qui se passent
pas toujours très bien des notamment 1
et donc il va y avoir aussi un sujet de
ceux de ce côté là
il est parfaitement possible que dans la
foulée de ce qui est en train de se
passer je parlais tout à l'heure d'une
canicule on se prennent une nouvelle
vague de réfugiés
voilà ça fait aussi partie des choses
qui sont possibles je ne sais pas quel
horizon de temps en fait ça n'est qu'une
question de temps
donc le on a on a aussi un sujet de ce
côté là qui est de savoir quelles
répercussions dans le monde va avoir le
retour du baril à un prix très bas qu'on
n'avait pas connu depuis une vingtaine
d'années alors que dans le même temps un
certain nombre d'états se sont
développées en comptant sur une manne
pétrolière qui était la fa se sont
développés se sont organisés plus
exactement en comptant sur une manne
pétrolière beaucoup plus abondante que
celle qu'on a aujourd'hui donc c'est
aussi un facteur d'instabilité qui
pourrait très bien se rappeler adou
d'une façon désagréable dans l'est dans
les mois et les années à venir
alors les autres questions qui avait été
posé un site ya une question qui vient
déposer à la volée est-ce que la fonte
du permafrost peut libérer des nouveaux
virus alors je n'ai pas la réponse à
cette question là et je suis mal
documenté laisser fait partie des choses
qu'il faudrait que je regarde sur la les
éventualités possibles en ce qui
concerne les micro organismes qui
pourraient être
décongeler venir à cause de la fonte du
permafrost
je n'ai pas la réponse en tout cas c'est
une question il me semble avoir vu
passer mais je suis totalement incapable
de savoir si c'est un rooks ou si c'est
quelque chose de sérieux
il me semble avoir vu passer à une
époque un sujet sur l'anthrax
voilà mais je sais pas du tout si
c'était un canular ou si c'est un aussi
c'est quelque chose de sérieux
[Musique]
allez à ce que j'ai prévu une réserve
alimentaire
non j'ai comme d'habitude quelques
paquets de café dans la peau dans dans
la cave
voilà les quelques paquets de pâtes mais
pas significativement plus que
d'habitude je confesse à travailler
d'acheter mes fruits et légumes ailleurs
qu'au marché où j'ai l'habitude d'aller
les acheter parce que j'avais peur que
ils interdisent des marchés de plein air
comme il en a été question à une époque
mais pour le moment ça n'arrive pas en
mieux donc aller chez les petits
commerçants
vous êtes moins confiné que dans les
grandes surfaces
et donc c'est tout aussi bien pour faire
ses courses
et puis en plus il ya les gens qui ont
normalement chez les commerçants bien
organisée en ce moment ils ont des gants
et il laisse pas n'importe qui tripotait
n'importe quoi sur les étals alors que
si vous allez dans les grandes surfaces
dans tout ce qui est en libre service et
bien les gens peuvent tripoter
exactement comme ils veulent les fruits
des légumes les paquets de gâteaux etc
donc je pense que encourent moins de
risques sanitaires
si on va au marché voit la fin de la
parenthèse sur mon organisation
alimentaire personnel la caisse que j'ai
d'autres qu'est ce que j'ai de votre
caisse que j'ai d'autres eh bien écoutez
je pense que j'ai à peu près fait le
tour de
[Musique]
ainsi non une question intéressante
celle sur le green washing un de mes
espoirs secrets
alors hein c'est un désespoir secret à
la fois comme chef d'entreprise très
égoïste 1 comme président de think tanks
mais aussi pour la collectivité
c'est que ce qui est en train de se
passer en ce moment permettent de mettre
un grand coup de [ __ ] de frein au
greenwashing
parce que on se rendra compte que ça
n'est pas une police d'assurance contre
les risques réels
voilà j'espère vraiment ça et
j'encourage vraiment tous les gens qui
sont en train d'écouter en ce moment à
essayer voilà si vous voulez faire un
tout petit truc qui peut être partagé
c'est d'essayer de faire valoir que tout
ce qui est greenwashing manifestement ça
ne permet pas d'éviter des emmerdements
puisque le greenwashing consiste par
essence non pas à traiter les problèmes
et à mettre le tas de poussière sous le
tapis en espérant qu'ils nous emmerdera
pas donc le monde j'ai vraiment un
secret espoir en ce moment c'est que le
toutes les sociétés qui ont dit vous
voyez le problème climatique
il est sous contrôle parce que on
compense parce que on a pris un
engagement à 2050
parce que etc vont être rappelés à
l'ordre
ils vont comprendre que le problème il
se traite pas dans 30 ans et il se
traite pas en faisant des déclarations
non suivies d'effet il se traite en
faisant aussi en interne entre
guillemets quelque chose qui ressemble à
une économie guerre c'est à dire à une
réorientation beaucoup plus rapide de ce
qui se fait aujourd'hui
ce qui veut dire que alors que
l'économie va souffrir
il faut quand même que les entreprises
dégagent des moyens pour s'occuper de ne
pas souffrir encore plus dans un délai
indéterminé à cause d'un problème
qu'aujourd'hui elle refuse de traiter d'
oncle
j'espère vraiment que cet épisode va
nous servir à montrer que de temps en
temps il faut savoir écouter les
cassandre
non pas pour avoir le moral qui part
dans les chaussettes mais simplement
pour comme je le disais tout à l'heure
comprendre qu'une analyse par scénario
c'est légitime comprendre que des sales
coups il peut vous en tomber sur la
figure et comprendre que le bon
arbitrage
c'est de dépenser un peu tout de suite
plutôt que de prendre le risque de
mourir plus tard ou de perdre une jambe
ou enfin d'avoir un dommage qui sera
beaucoup plus important je pense quand
même que c'est hallucinant quand on y
pense que on n'est pas osé jusqu'à
maintenant imposer aux entreprises
c'était de six ans d'un coup de gueule
que j'ai poussé il ya pas longtemps qui
à nouveau navale eu quelques
commentaires
quel on m'a expliqué que les dernières
fois jojo et jouer la mort des vieux je
trouve quand même hallucinant que on
décide
lorsque je trouve hallucinant c'est pas
qu'on le décide à un temps des moyens ça
je suis je n'ai pas de jugement moral là
dessus mais ce que je constate c'est que
on est d'accord pour sortir 300
milliards du placard et pour mettre
l'économie à l'arrêt 20 30 % de
l'économie à l'arrêt pour un problème
qui concerne 1 % de la population
essentiellement à g et symétriquement on
n'a pas jusqu'à maintenant étaient
capables de dépenser
ne serait-ce que le 100e de cette somme
en compréhension de à quelle distance
nous sommes du mur au motif que ça
allait faire du mal aux entreprises les
empêcher d'être compétitive et cetera
pour un problème qui est susceptible de
pourrir la totalité
la vie des enfants qui sont en train
d'être aujourd'hui donc je trouve ce
décalage choquant pour dire les choses
donc ça ne me choque pas qu'on s'occupe
du problème sanitaire aujourd'hui ça
vous choque que il ya une telle
asymétrie moyen entre ce qu'on est en
train de faire aujourd'hui est ce qu'on
aurait dû faire depuis longtemps qui
devrait en demander dix fois plus pour
traiter le problème futur
qu'est-ce qu'on n'a pas osé faire
jusqu'à maintenant on n'a pas par
exemple osé imposer aux entreprises de
tenir une comptabilité carbone digne de
ce nom
alors qu'est ce que ça coûte de tenir la
comptabilité carbone digne de ce nom ça
leur coûte 5 2 % de leur chiffre
d'affaires
bon très bien ça leur coûte 1 % du
chiffre d'affaires soit ça fait vivre
par ailleurs les gens qui vont le faire
on n'a pas aujourd'hui imposées aux
entreprises de faire de la que soit
imposée aux acheteurs publics par
exemple être sérieux sur cette question
qu'est ce que ça coûte ça coûte de les
former on n'a pas imposé aux entreprises
de se former sérieusement sur la
question qu'est ce que ça coûte pas
grand chose
voilà donc on n'a pas imposé aux
entreprises des mesures qui sont sur le
fond considérablement moins coercitives
que ce que aujourd'hui on est en train
de s'imposer
donc le fait de lutter anglais de partir
en guerre pardon contre le greenwashing
est une manière de contribuer à ce que
demain on se rende compte qu'il ya
d'autres combats qui mérite que l'on se
donne des contraintes et il n'ya rien
d'illégitime à se donner des contraintes
je répète une chose que j'ai déjà
souvent dit aussi c'est les entreprises
toutes les entreprises la mienne y
compris ninove que sous la contrainte
il n'y a pas d'innovation sans
contrainte dans le monde des normands
des entreprises et tous les gens qui
écoutent et qui font partie du monde
dans l'entreprise se sert très bien
il n'existe pas de
de l'innovation sans contrainte à est ce
que vous pouvez composer quelque chose
d'intelligent contre le greenwashing me
demande alexandre et bien la réponse est
oui ça fait partie des projets que le
chef de projet vous les mettre en route
et donc on va le faire
alors en fait on va le faire à l'envers
on va faire le parfait manuel du green
washers c'est à dire si vous voulez gris
gouache et à fond voilà quelques bonnes
recettes
quand vous conseille d'utiliser mais du
coup ça dira en creux les choses à ne
pas faire et le les mesures qui ont qui
ont du sens mais oui ça fait partie de
ça fait partie de nos dos de nos projets
on a ça dans l'est on a ça dans les
dents les tuyaux eh bien on s'oriente
doucettement vers la fin à puisqu'on
parlait des jeunes quel conseil est ce
que je pourrais donner aux jeunes de 16
17 ans qui sont pétris d'anxiété et bien
la réponse est je pense que ce n'est pas
tant une affaire de fond qu'une affaire
de forme c'est à dire que les gens qui
sont pétris d'anxiété d'une manière
générale c'est qui leur est utile c'est
être accompagnés
c'est qu'ils sentent que l'on est proche
c'est qu'on est qu'on s'occupe d'eux et
que on a on a envie de faire des choses
pour donc sans vouloir grandiloquent la
bonne réponse c'est la bourre et
l'empathie c'est la première la deuxième
bonne réponse c'est de les aider à
comprendre parce que comprendre ce qui
se passe c'est quand même toujours une
forme de libération de l'angola ce même
si ce qui est en train de se passer
n'est pas toujours très rose et donc il
ya un deuxième truc qui marche crois
qu'ils s'appellent
l'enseignement ou les explications je
pense que ça aussi une vertu
puis un troisième truc qui s'appelle
l'action tout bêtement quand on est ado
en général on rédaction en réalisation
transgressive mais on rêve d'action donc
la troisième chose à faire c'est de c2c
de les mettre dans l'action c'est la
troisième
me semble utile des choses qui est qui
est utile voilà voilà
à dernier point les jeux finir avec ça
le confinement actuel fait exploser les
flux vidéo alors oui et en fait le
confinement actuel fait explore mai mais
aussi semblerait-il le réseau un peu
sous tension parce que il ya un milliard
de gens qui sont en train en ce moment
de remplacer leurs rangs des maux
physiques par des rendez-vous
téléphonique ou en vidéo moi même je ne
déroge pas puisque c'est pas
complètement sûr que ce facebook live
aurait eu lieu si on n'avait pas décidé
des mesures de confinement
j'espère que vous êtes tous en train de
me regarder en hyper basse définition
d'abord comme ça envoie - les poils de
narines et de toute façon vous n'avez
pas besoin vous quand même regarder son
image ça marche aussi bien
donc le donc là il semblerait en ce
moment où il ya un petit sujet de
surcharge sur le réseau internet donc
oui effectivement c'est le moment par
excellence
pour
[Musique]
c'est le moment par excellence pour tout
mettre en basse définition si possible
avec juste le son pour essayer de
prendre quelques bonnes habitudes
il ya quelqu'un qui est également
proposé de conques au mans sa lancée un
jour de diète réticulaire on sait pas si
c'est en ce moment qu'il faut le faire
parce qu'on est privé de toute
interaction par ailleurs puisqu'on peut
pas aller se serrer la louche
allez allez bouffer chez les uns chez
les autres c'est mais je trouvais que
c'était une idée intéressante d'essayer
de se mettre à la diète réticulaire un
certain nombre d'heures ou une journée
par semaine
voilà je trouve je trouve ça intéressant
j'espère également que le moratoire de
fait qui vient d'être lancée sur la 5 g
puisque la flotte or depuis ce qu'il
vient de se passer
on a un tout petit peu repoussé les
enchères va donner un peu plus le temps
de se muscler sûr est ce que vraiment au
moment où on va chercher à faire
repartir l'emploi
on a besoin de pousser les gens à
changer tous leurs smartphones importés
et les équipementiers à utiliser plein
de nouveautés enfin et les opérateurs de
réseaux pardon à faire appel à des
équipements importés tout ça pour
télécharger plus rapidement des vidéos
où est ce que l'expérience récente vient
de nous montrer qu'on avait d'autres
chats à fouetter
comme je suis d'un naturel optimiste eh
bien j'espère que c'est la deuxième
éventualité qui sera retenue par la
première est que ce projet sera sagement
remise est dans les cartons dont il
avait dû sortir et que à ce moment là on
s'occupera de faire des choses un peu
plus essentiel pour garantir une société
résidente à l'avenir je pas complètement
sûr que la 5 g va augmenter la
résilience de la société et ça sera le
goût de la fin en fait on a vraiment
besoin
encore une fois la faveur de l'épisode
qui est en train de se produire en ce
moment que le projet pour l'avenir
embarque l'idée qu' il faut faire une
société qui soit plus résiliente et on a
été trop anesthésié par le confort
passait pour être pour avoir été capable
de se mettre dans l'état d'esprit où on
raisonne comme ça et il faut espérer que
le petit électrochoc parce qu'il faut
savoir gardons rézé savoir raison garder
pardon dyslexie quand il tient donc il
faut savoir raison garder dans le dans
le contexte actuel ce que nous sommes en
train de vivre est un petit électrochoc
je ne crois pas du tout que la société
va complètement partir en vrille et
qu'on va retourner aux cavernes neuf à
cause de ce qui est en train de se
passer en ce moment mais ça serait très
utile que l'épisode actuel nous servent
à comprendre que c'est le début d'une
réorientation et c'est comme vous
puisque c'était ça la question la plus
interne à plus la plus plébiscitée de
tout j'espère vraiment que ça va inciter
à la réflexion et quelques petits
signaux faibles dans les discours
présidentiels récent qui peuvent laisser
espérer que cette pensée n'est pas
totalement absente de quelques
réflexions en cours mais c'est évident
qu'il va falloir
considérablement appuyer sur la [ __ ]
d'accélérateur sans mauvais jeu de mots
de ce côté là voilà eh bien merci à tous
ceux qui ont été suffisamment patient
pour attendre cette heure ci avant de
décrocher
soyez bien confiné profitez-en bien
essayé de ne pas trop stresser ne pas
trop mal supporté cet épisode actuelle
une pensée particulière pour tous ceux
qui sont vraiment coincé dans un petit
appartement dans un endroit où ils n'ont
pas la possibilité d'aller prendre
passer facilement l'air voilà je vous
souhaite que cet épisode soit le moins
douloureux possible
à bientôt